Thanks for having me.
Thanks for being here.
Appreciate it.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
The opinions you're about to hear it.
Do you not represent national geographic
or anybody other than us?
That's it.
And even us,
we're not sure of it.
We're not committed to these,
these statements.
Adam,
welcome.
Thanks Jack.
Thanks fucker.
Right in front of your face there.
Thanks for having me,
Jeff.
Cliche.
Appreciate it,
man.
Dude,
you live a life of adventure.
This is a.
I was so excited when you contacted me
and I went to your instagram page and
saw the photos and saw the places you've
been and looked you up,
man.
He live in a crazy life.
I do a bit of traveling,
that's for sure.
A few frequent flyer miles,
man.
I mean so much adventure.
So many different places and so much
cool shit you've seen.
Like what?
How did you get into this?
I kind of grew up doing it.
Tell you the truth.
I had a family.
He made a nature documentaries,
so as a family unit,
that's what we did for a living and so I
was traveling from.
Well,
the moment I could walk basically.
Wow.
That is cool.
What is your.
Your dad is like a filmmaker or
something?
Yeah,
I your mom.
I should say your mom or your dad?
I'm so solid family unit sort of thing.
What about,
I guess,
how do you explain that in a nutshell?
He kind of,
the Australian Jacques Cousteau,
maybe the Australian version of that.
Maybe he started off as a shock content
back in the sixties,
so it was actually putting shocks and
putting that.
I'm filming it,
putting it on TV with Leonard Nimoy was
narrating spock was actually narrating
them back in.
He'll never be anything but sparked.
I know,
I know.
I love that place.
You get fucked man.
You have a role too.
Good.
Um,
and then he turned conservationist,
you know,
after probably bid sixties or something.
So he was a hunter.
So he was going out and killing sharks
and then he,
what,
what made him sort of shift into
conservation?
I think it was just a realization of
just,
yeah,
what a,
what a waste,
you know,
killing shocks.
And also,
I think after you spend enough time with
sharks in the water,
you realize they're not dangerous at
all.
These things.
A magnificent creatures.
They're not under most circumstances.
I mean they're obviously,
they do kill.
They get hungry occasionally.
Yeah.
I mean the problem is really we look
like seals on a surf board,
right?
Then that's a real problem.
It's taking identity a nine times out of
10 mistaken identity.
And the only way they can figure out
what you are is by coming up and taking
a little bite and surf board and
wetsuit.
But that one little box can sometimes be
fate a killer.
But it's very rare.
It's very rare to get eaten by a shark.
Yeah.
Fairly rare.
Not Rare enough.
Once again,
I mean,
I should just clarify.
I'm not in favor of killing sharks.
I'm not interested in eradicating them
from the ocean,
but they scare the shit out of me,
man.
I was uh,
in California,
in California now,
but it was like a couple years ago,
some guy,
this is my biggest fear.
Some guy was swimming with a bunch of
people that were training for a
triathlon and it was off the coast of
San Diego and he was bitten in half in
front of everybody.
You know,
I mean it does go down,
but perspective kill a hundred or 100
million sharks a year.
Well now you and I,
so probably shouldn't we as humanity?
Yes.
Humanity kills 100 million in the suit.
We killed.
They killed maybe eight to 10 of us.
I think it's less than that.
I think it's like five.
Yeah,
it depends what you get the statistics
from accounting because I mean most
Fatah fatalities and it comes to shock
attacks.
Actually.
The Zambezi,
the bullshit because in Africa don't
have great records.
Um,
but I would say yeah,
eight to 10 per year.
The crazy thing about bull sharks is
they can live in freshwater,
like deep,
deep,
deep in freshwater rivers.
They're kind of blind.
They can only see about six inches in
front of their face.
So they like rivers and dirty kind of
water.
I spent two years swimming everyday with
a,
Oh,
it's about three meters.
Bull shock in captivity as soon as you
stood up the water,
she would come ride.
And she loved it when it was murky
because that's when she had the
advantage over the other animals.
Oh,
interesting.
Well,
you know,
the basis for the movie jaws was
actually a freshwater shark attack.
It was baffling to people.
They had no idea that sharks at the time
would even exist in fresh water,
but it was in New Jersey and these
people are in a river and I think two
people were killed inside of a short
period of time by bull sharks that it's
swim,
sound,
right,
swim up river and uh,
in fresh water.
So these people were at our freshwater
beach by the river and they get killed.
Everyone's scared of the great white,
you know,
the big shock.
But if you talk about the amount of a
tax bill shock is Fafa hm.
That's interesting.
And then you think it's because they're
young,
they don't see.
Well,
so it's a mistaken identity thing.
it's,
once again,
they,
they see you using the electrical,
uh,
receptive.
So that I can think of,
see hot beating basically,
but it doesn't know what you are and
it's got really bad vision.
So the only way you can figure out what
you are and whether your edible is to
come and take a little bite and you
know,
that little block sometimes can be
fatal.
Yeah.
I saw something last night.
I think it's got to be bullshit.
I wish I could remember the name of it,
but it was a camouflage suit that you
could wear while hunting that does not
give out the electrical signal.
So it was like a,
it was close.
It was somehow or another.
The,
these clothes keep an electrical signal
from like animals from seeing this
electrical signal.
I,
it sounded like horseshit though.
Well I mean there is some science that
if you have a faraday cage suit.
So what does it live in a Faraday cage?
Totally.
The middle.
Basically woven.
That stops a electrical stuff.
Jamie,
is that real make significant human
significantly less detectable by
animals?
No,
it would.
It would sense for sure with
animals that have the electrical impulse
receptors like sharks do.
Huh?
Well,
sharks have that line on their body,
right?
That's what it is.
Well,
a all fish have a line going,
lateral line going down in that detects
the,
you know,
electrical impulses,
but sharks have on the nose.
Um,
it's a really hard word to pronounce
them.
Look on trying,
but they have this electrical receptor
on the front of their nose.
And so when a shark sees you,
it can actually see your heart beating.
And so say you're swimming with sharks
and someone else next to you and you've
been,
um,
you've never been.
You've been swimming with sharks before.
You pretty calm.
So your heart's going,
blah,
blah.
Person next to you and never been
swimming with sharks before.
Freaking out their hearts going,
blah,
blah.
A million miles an hour that shark's
gonna swim up and go lunch person with a
faster happy because they're stressed
out,
they're going to be easier to catch.
Nature does not like bitches.
That's what it is.
Panic like a bitch.
Nature's like [inaudible].
It's true.
If you panic when you're in with sharks,
they'll come right up to you.
They want to check your animals,
right?
You ever seen people that just freak out
around dogs and dogs start barking at
them and then another person come up
with that dog.
Hey Buddy,
what's going on?
You all right?
You know?
Yeah.
So your dad was a shark hunter.
And when he was hunting these sharks,
was he doing it for food?
Were they eating the sharks?
This was,
I mean,
you gotta remember this is back in the
day,
you know,
this is kind of,
and c's sixties,
early sixties.
And back then it was,
he was filming people killing,
you know,
20,
30 shocks,
uh,
at a time.
And it was just a,
was the first underwater documentaries
out there sort of showing that world.
And they were using explosive headset,
like a spear gun with a bullet 300,
three on the end of it.
Oh Wow.
And they were shooting them that way.
But,
uh,
you know,
I look at those videos now and some of
the species that we're killing it just
completely harmless and it's just.
And I guess it eventually to get to that
point where they turned around and went,
oh,
hang on,
this is bad,
and so use that fame or that desire for
this underwater footage and then,
and then sort of take a conservation
angle to it instead.
So there were,
they initially doing it to eradicate
dangerous animals.
Is that whether we're doing it,
I guess there's that aspect of that to
tell the truth.
I think it was just good tv.
Oh,
okay.
So it was just let's go shoot some shit
and put it on television and here's
sharks.
And everyone's scared of them,
you know,
that's,
it was quite a natural thing back then
to go,
you're scared of something could kill
it.
And so your dad,
while you were young,
became a conservationist and then
started taking you all around the world.
Yeah.
So we made these kinds of,
one our nature documentaries.
Um,
they were shown in Australia on channel
seven over here,
Disney channel pick them up.
Um,
this trend around the world and uh,
mainly underwater kind of adventure.
I look back now and I actually think
it's kind of reality TV to the truth
because it's a,
it's a documentary of a family going on
an adventure and learning some stuff and
seeing some cool stuff on the way.
Wow.
So this has been your life all along?
Yeah.
Wow,
that's cool man.
And so how'd you get involved with
nationally?
You're a national geographic expedition
leader.
I worked for a company called Linblad
expeditions,
National Geographic.
So it's a partnership between Lindblad
expeditions at National Geographic and
we've got a fleet of 10 vessels and we
take people to the remotest places on it
basically.
And so they graciously give me a
$100,000,000
ship and 100 people on it and a kind of
a,
you start here and you end here two
weeks later and yeah,
go for an adventure.
Go see what you can file.
Dad Is fucking bad.
It's good fun.
It's,
you know,
it's a lot of work.
I don't like anything you get paid for
this work to it,
but um,
yeah,
the perks are just phenomenal.
The perks are made $100,
million dollar vessel.
Yeah.
Wow,
it's a nice ship.
It's a beautiful ship,
national geographic or right.
It's one of the best exhibition ships
floating at this point in time.
And so like when you go on these ships,
like what are the ultimate goals are to
collect samples to view things,
to take photographs to try to view rare
species,
bit of everything really.
Uh,
so we have scientists on board doing
some research and stuff like that.
Um,
but we're also taking tourists,
you know,
we're taking people who are paying a
considerable amount of money.
I can go to those.
I can go on a tour,
official can come down to Antarctica
with me.
Woo.
It's too cold.
I want to go somewhere.
Cool.
And tactic is just got back from Costa
Rica where they invite me to that.
That's bad ass.
I have to point out,
I do it.
My friend down,
they've,
Conrad said,
make sure you invite joe down here.
Is that your boat?
Um,
yeah.
National Geographic or Ryan,
you're on a cruise ship.
It's not a cruise ship.
We have to be very specific about this.
It's just say it's not a cruise ship.
That's a fucking cruise ship.
There's.
There's a difference between expedition
and cruising.
Okay,
so a cruise ship goes to,
goes to port,
deport you,
you stop in at some town,
you go after you explore the town for
the day,
you come back,
you jump on the ship,
he goes to the next destination.
We don't go to towns.
We go to places in between.
We'd go to remote places.
We've got 13 zodiacs onboard.
So little small vessels to live in like
a gangster on this thing.
Look at this.
Look,
you got a hot tub.
Come on.
If you were a Russian oligarch,
this is what I would expect.
Look at these.
What are these rock piles?
Why do you have rocks?
Um,
yeah.
They got removed about last week.
They got removed because they were like,
why do we have rocks that design 10
years old.
Oh,
okay.
I see.
So that's 2006.
It's not like we're talking about the
twenties.
Back then people didn't know any better.
So you had these,
these rocks are there just for.
Looks like it's going to kill me if I
talk about the rocks too long.
But when a few weeks ago I saw them
removing them so they're not been the
rocks near there.
It seems like a lot of weight to be
carrying around just to look pretty.
Come on.
They're fiberglass rocks.
Oh,
they're fake rocks.
You wouldn't put rocks on top of the
ship.
Get these photos.
You guys partying.
You know,
it's like a Jay z video.
Yeah.
We have cocktail parties all the time.
Boop,
boop.
And Wow.
That is a bad ass boat to be touring
around with.
I spent new years dancing and partying
on the ice in Antarctica.
Whoa.
Yeah.
We have some good parties on there.
We do.
Did you see any polar bears,
polar bears in Antarctica?
No,
they're not in Antarctica.
That's penguins.
Penguins.
Penguins on the sound winds in the
north.
Right.
What,
what kind of mammals do they have in
Antarctica though?
Oh,
lots.
I mean you've got all your different
well spaces.
So blue whales,
fin whales say whales,
humpback whales,
minke whales and orcas.
Um,
and you know,
a lot of different dolphins as well.
And then of course you seals,
you pin a pitts.
I'm so elephant seals,
a leopard suit,
leopard seals.
It seals a pretty cool.
Those are the wildest man I remember
when I saw that in March of the penguins
movie and there's the first time I
really found out about leopard seals or
had seen them in like a,
you know,
high definition video form.
I think maybe had seen a photograph of
him before,
but I didn't realize like what a
majestic beasts they are,
but a strange,
almost like a fake animal.
It doesn't even look real.
I think of him like a swimming jewel.
Just this huge big Joel with massive
team there.
See the size of the teeth on them and
they,
they eat penguins and occasionally they
chew on the back of Zodiacs as well.
Zodiacs or those boats?
We have probably about one a year.
They ended up chewing on the back of the
Zodiac.
So because they're inflatable boat,
why does they do that?
To fuck with people?
Probably just to fuck with people.
Well,
they're really weird because like,
uh,
there was one account that this
photographer did a,
it was several days where he spent
filming a female leopard seal and she
kept bringing him penguins to eat.
And He.
Have you heard of this?
No,
it was really fascinating because,
uh,
he was terrified,
you know,
this monstrous,
enormous,
predatory and have respect for them.
Oh yeah.
They're huge.
And she kept bringing him like dead
penguins and like bringing it to my,
come on,
eat it,
bitch.
And he,
she,
I guess she felt bad for him or she was
just trying to make friends with them or
some sort of strange thing,
like she's not in a position where she
was famished where she didn't have.
She had plenty of food so she wasn't
looking to eat him,
so she just decided to help him and try
to feed him.
It was very,
very strange.
I mean,
the golden rule with sort of biology is
don't put human emotions onto animals,
but the closer you look at animals,
more time you spend with the animals,
you see these emotions,
you see elements of culture.
Also,
some stuff going on.
Um,
yeah.
We don't give him enough respect.
We don't have to give humans now.
Pull.
Pull that up.
This is it right here.
How a leopard seal fed me penguins.
It's really crazy.
They have video footage of it too.
I think if you press the video you'll
see this.
Uh,
it's really crazy.
The,
this gigantic thing very well for the
videos.
Oh,
okay.
No worries.
We don't have to show it,
but um,
folks can find it online.
How a leopard seal.
Is that the name of it?
How a leopard seal fed me penguins.
Amazing.
And that's national geographic as well.
That's your,
your folks.
Yeah.
I recognize the over correction.
Um,
I kind of had a similar experience quite
a few years ago.
The Chew Gum.
You ever heard of a Jugo?
I've heard the word,
but what is it during the Iranian
family?
Closest relative is manatee Chigong.
It's kind of,
you know,
what a manatee is.
So think of a manatee and then instead
of like a beaver tail,
put a dolphin tail on it.
It's very small differences,
but basically the same thing.
And there was this one in Vanuatu and it
lost its partner,
um,
and so every day what I do is catch
turtles and bring it up to the beach and
just push them up on the beach for the
locals to eat.
And so every day he would catch all the
food the locals would need.
Whoa.
And then they befriended it and it was
one of the juveniles in the world that
you could actually swim and play with.
We did a documentary on it called the
elusive mermaid.
So I spent a quite a few weeks with this
crazy credit.
So strains like the personality
diversity in these animals,
like glue that.
There it is.
Whoa.
That thing is crazy looking.
Huge.
Chabad 900 kilograms.
It's D U,
g o n g for anybody who's interested do
gone to,
gone to gung what a crazy looking
animal.
They are there.
They're sometimes called the sea cow.
They eat about 40 kilograms of seagrass
a day.
So wireless amount of food.
That's insane.
Sometimes called the elusive mermaid as
well because at sale is back in the day.
Used to mistake them for four nights.
That's.
Yeah,
well you to be drinking a lot around
that,
that some people just get so desperado
after long periods of time alone.
Yeah,
that's a wild wild animal though.
It's strange that it would try to feed
people and they have no idea what the
motivation is.
Right.
Um,
once again,
like if you anthropomorphize it just
wanted interaction and one of their very
close knit social structure.
So when you have a group of them
together,
they're all together.
They're very tactile,
rubbing up against each other.
So if it was in the middle of nowhere,
there's no more geographies around it.
Just decided to befriend the locals and
kind of go that way.
And there's lots of evidence with lots
of animals doing that kind of
friendships going on.
And I've got a good story,
if you,
if you give me a second for the juggle.
I nearly got killed budget go
accidentally or tried to,
tried to kill me.
So I was filming this documentary
elusive moment and so we've doing lots
and lots of video and so I went to this
one in Vanuatu and we're filming him and
in the water playing with him and stuff
like that.
And he really liked females,
didn't lock humans,
humans love.
So he would have some new data issues.
He would chase and harassed miles
basically.
But back in those days I had long,
long hair.
Sounds like Jamie,
Jamie,
there's only.
So I had long hair so I kind of fooled,
folded basically that he thought he was,
it was all real casual with me.
And then he would,
um,
he would grab your leg basically and he
would on your wetsuit and clean his
mouth on it and stuff like that.
It's very tactile.
Definitely grabbing your tongue in his
mouth on your leg.
All the bristles in front of his nose.
He was just kind of cleaned that on your
wet suit and stuff.
He was just very tactile.
And so one time he was doing that and he
kind of went a little bit too far up my
leg and he felt something.
He went,
I saw him,
he looked at me and you're not female,
you're male,
and so he attacked me and so what he did
is he,
he grabbed me and then it's 900 kilogram
animal or you got no hope,
so he grabbed me,
holding my arms against my chest,
sort of thing.
Took me down to about five meters on the
sandy bottom and just held me against
the sandy bottom,
trying to kill you.
Well,
I'm kicking and thrashing and I'm
punching.
I'm doing everything I can to get out of
this bear hug from this Chigong and um,
oh,
I was down there for a minute and a
half,
two minutes and I'm excited to get them
black coming in on the vision.
And I remember clear as day just
thinking death by Jugo didn't see that
one coming.
And then as soon as I gave up,
you know,
just kind of stopped fighting.
He just let me go.
It was just a game.
It's just a game for him.
He just wanted to prove dominance
basically.
Whoa.
And obviously he doesn't have any data
as far as how many minutes a person can
hold
breath for they die as soon as I stopped
fighting and I just gave into,
to the fact of death by Juggle,
he let me go and I was wearing a wetsuit
so it's kind of brought me back to the
surface.
But yeah,
that was a near death experience for me.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
How terrifying and weird.
So he felt like you tricked him?
Um,
well yeah,
I told him.
I mean he was,
I was there and uh,
there was a honeymoon couple there as
well.
It was a little resort where we call it
resort and like shacks in the forest
kind of thing.
And I remember sitting there at dinner
one time and now the new wife is going,
oh,
come on honey,
jumped in the water with the Jew going
to barneys please.
Like no way.
I'm not hopping in because he would just
get attacked every time.
So he really didn't like males.
That's so strange.
I wonder what it is about you just long
hair.
Like how could they,
how could they know?
The cultural differences between the way
humans were,
their hair.
It's interesting point.
I mean you could speculate and just go,
well,
he's just recognizing,
you know,
there's all hippie long hair people and
non long hair people at.
I don't know how the fuck would he know
animals or we need more data.
Do you think that's what it is?
Or the thing is you,
with your long experience,
lifelong experience being around animals
that maybe you were more relaxed so he
was cool with you.
Yeah,
that's definitely an aspect.
Maybe Mandolin and they give off that
energy of gone.
Yeah.
I mean that definitely could be.
No,
you back off bitch and then he attacks
him and the girls like don't hurt me.
And he's like,
I'm good.
We're good.
Maybe just like people to be submissive.
Quite pop that right?
Yeah.
This,
you know,
the whole Alpha thing.
It's going on everywhere.
Yeah.
It's a strange,
strange looking animal man.
That would be a weird animal to kill
you.
Yeah.
I definitely didn't expect.
I didn't expect to have a near death
experience with juggle because you can
barely get near these creatures.
Normally a fleeting glimpse in the in
the far distances.
All you ever see these animals,
so is it when they're around resorts or
something like that where they become
accustomed to humans or around where
there's large populations.
Think
I have another time juggle this one.
He died or left or something went wrong
a few years back and I can't recall any
other time geographies around the world
except in captivity.
I spent a bit of time with a tube in
captivity at seaworld on the Gold Coast
in Australia and yeah,
there were a bit messed up actually like
most animals in captivity.
Well,
it's like that lion whisper cat.
What's that dude's name?
The handsome fella that's always on
television.
He's on the Jimmy Kimmel show all the
time and he's always hanging around with
lions.
Yeah,
and he sees the line is like Hulu would
you do in the lion comes up to him.
He gives him a hug.
I'm like,
okay,
how the fuck did you ever work that out?
Hey,
what color?
How do you work out that relationship?
Is that the guy now?
That's one of them.
I think just probably more than one of
these dudes obviously looks very 90,
nine times out of 100.
That's the.
Well apparently this is what,
from what I understand,
like lions and big cats,
tigers and lions,
when you have them as pets and you raise
them as pets and you get used to them
accustomed to them,
there's so not intimidated by you.
As long as they're well fed,
you're pretty safe.
They're most likely not gonna fuck you
up,
but they might fuck up other people who
are around you and panic and don't know
how to deal and they're like,
why don't you bring this asshole here?
I like hanging out with you and then
they just whack them.
You know?
I don't think we give enough respectful
animals.
I mean just you,
your dog,
your dog.
Like some people and doesn't like other
people and you should always listened to
your dope.
Yeah,
knows best will.
You dog definitely knows when people are
shady.
You know when you have someone over and
the dog started growling.
Like what the fuck is going on man?
You know,
tap dogs know when people are
comfortable,
that's for sure.
You know,
I,
I knew this lady,
she had these crazy German shepherds
man,
but I've been around dogs my whole life
and I was cool with them and she was
surprised and she was like,
you know,
normally when these dogs around people
that ground,
they want to bite them.
I'm like,
why don't you fucking do something about
your dogs then?
Like everybody,
like your dog thinks everybody's an
asshole.
Like that's probably on you.
That's,
that's bad training or
using positive reinforcement.
If you use that technique you can get up
to do anything.
Any animal and will anyone.
I think she liked having aggressive dogs
and she liked having people intimidated
around her and her dogs,
you know?
But anyway,
that's neither here nor there.
You've been bitten by a box jellyfish?
Yes.
Dude,
I've been stung.
Technical bitten their face.
You've been looked at and read.
You've been read the riot act now they
don't have my mouth.
And you get.
How'd you stung or do you,
did
you not know it was there?
Like what?
I didn't know what to say.
Obviously I was about 12 years old in
Torres Strait,
which is a bunch of islands in between
Australia and Papa New Guinea and I was
playing with a holly Patar Strait
islanders,
a local boys.
I'm playing in the ocean,
you know,
just swimming around.
And then I had one wraparound.
My,
my leg quadricep.
Um,
yeah,
a lot of pain.
I've heard a women who've had children
have said that I've said that it's,
it's far superior pain to childbirth
that superior,
like they enjoy a better or a far worse
basically in orders of magnitude worse
than childbirth is how they relate the
pain.
You'd probably have to talk to someone
who's been stung by a bullet ant,
which is supposed to be one of the most
painful things.
I wouldn't wonder who's got the.
She's got the know,
like if you get someone to listen.
I know you've been stung by a bullet in.
I'd like to encourage you to try the box
jellyfish and tell me it's um,
yeah,
it's a lot of pain.
It's a kind of pain where you have to
scream expletives,
you know,
you can't just sit there and take it.
You have to be screaming something
because it's that painful.
It's super deadly to the very old and
the very young.
Um,
it depends.
Done.
Yeah.
That's,
that's actually pretty good.
We're talking very young five,
six.
We're talking about the amount of toxin
to body mass basis.
So if you're,
if you're a little tiny kid,
then that's a lot of toxin for a small
body nets.
If you're very old,
then it's heart attacks,
aneurysms,
that sort of stuff.
Wow.
Aneurysms fucking well just it messes
you up.
The pain.
It causes heart attacks or just freak
out.
Yeah.
Too much pain.
So just the physical sensation of pain
is the catalyst for these heart attacks
and all these different things,
but you just,
your body freaks out.
I mean,
you aren't getting stung by a
neurotoxin.
Don't get me wrong.
There's a little in the tentacles of the
box jellyfish.
There's new mattresses,
a little tiny poisons,
dots basically,
and when it touches something
biological,
um,
so that's why you can wear tiny little
thin lycra suit or pantyhose,
whatever,
as long as there's something in between
your skin and the box jellyfish will
never stink.
But if it touches something biological,
then these little poisonous darts,
fire and they fire into your skin and
they inject a neurotoxin and it makes
for an incredible amount of pain.
Incredible.
And uh,
the first day back then was vinegar.
We had a bottle of vinegar I remember
clear as day.
My Dad came over and he got the bottle
of vinegar,
two liter bottle of vinegar and you just
put one little splash on there and then
put the lid back up and I'm sort of
screaming and I'm like,
what?
Raul bottle on there?
But he,
he wanted to save some in case some of
the local got stung as well.
So you could.
Oh my God.
It's saving them for some folks he
doesn't even know I got one splash dad.
Yeah,
I was,
I was screaming some explainers Adam
over that one.
So how long does the pain last?
Um,
it was about six hours before I just
passed out.
It was six hours of pain sitting there
screaming,
expletives,
and then I,
I guess I just talked myself out,
you know,
and then I passed out.
I'm still painful for probably about six
months.
Five months.
Six months.
Yeah.
It lasts for a long time.
Not as severe as that first six hours.
But it's still.
Yeah,
it's six months.
I don't recommend it now.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
Is that the worst thing to happen,
like with,
from an animal other than death?
Like as far as like pain that my being,
I've never heard anything that lasts six
months.
I'm sure getting mauled by a lion would
probably.
Yeah.
But you know,
that would be death,
but you're talking about like damage,
like that's ripping your tissue apart
and breaking bones and things along
those lines.
Yeah.
You're,
what you're having is just this little
tiny needles and it affects you for six
months and that's not the worst
jellyfish.
Everyone goes,
box,
jellyfish,
current next flicker.
I,
they were all like,
oh,
that's the worst one.
Will actually,
that's what's the worst one,
Cold Era Kanji.
Um,
it's actually a whole heap of them,
but they lumped them all together into
this era.
Kanji,
I'm sort of group and they're tiny.
They're the size of your pinky
fingernail.
Absolutely tiny.
Um,
and the pain from them is more severe
than a box.
Jelly fish.
Oh,
crushed.
Yeah.
And,
and you don't even feel the steam.
Why don't we find them and kill them all
my love.
What's,
what's wrong?
Why is everybody not enough research?
Not enough research on them yet.
We still don't know a lot about them.
Yeah.
The Russians are going to use him for
toxic.
They're gonna.
Drop my Manhattan.
A big balloon.
Blame the Russians don't need names.
Some evil people that you don't know.
I just love everyone.
Always blames the Russians.
Yeah.
Well,
it's convenient.
You've been accustomed to it in TV and
movies for the last few decades said,
well,
when we were kids,
the real thing was when I was a kid and
I was in high school,
it was always.
We're worried about the Russians nuking
us more worried about,
you know,
we'd heard about the Cuban missile
crisis,
the standoff,
and everybody's always terrified that
one day there was always the stories
that,
you know,
there was one time where we almost went
to war with Russia.
There was almost a mistake and they
thought missiles were in the air and
they almost sent missiles,
have their own mutual assured
destruction.
That actually happened quite a few
times,
you know,
so that was a gigantic fear in America.
But you guys movies,
the bad guy was always rest assure will
be eastern European of some description.
It's ironic really because I mean it
went away for a little while.
Now it's back.
Not really ironic but interesting that
now back with with Putin is the most
potent example of like the scary Russian
guy ever.
Kgb Judo,
black belt,
completely dominating this country and
some sort of a strange way.
Anytime there's some sort of political
adversary,
they magically wind up getting shot and
public.
Nobody goes to jail for it.
There's a lot of corruption all around
the world and I find it funny that we
always pick that out.
I guess I'm more aligned with probably
Abby Martin
on this one.
I love your interviews with.
That'd be mountain by the way.
That.
Yeah,
they do some bad shit,
but they also do some good stuff as
well.
Yeah,
it's.
Everyone's got the bad side and good.
So he's openly gangster though in a
weird way.
Like in good.
In good ways and also in bad ways.
He's pretty openly gangster.
Yeah.
Have you ever watched him?
He does the sort of public question and
answer sessions for about two hours once
a year or something.
Oh,
does he have a watch?
It's really interesting to watch them
actually.
He's a very smart,
very,
very smart man and even I've even seen
humor in it as well.
Very,
very briefly.
But this humor,
he likes trump.
No.
Really thinks trump would be a good
president.
You Shit me?
Nope.
Okay.
Let's.
That's his guy.
Older respect to head from Putin is now
discipline.
I might've made that up.
Check it,
check it,
check.
I don't even trust me when I look at
putting ice,
he wants to build it.
That's what he wants.
He wants stability,
stability,
and trump is not cash.
You don't think they're that trump and
Putin is over.
It's over.
What happened?
I didn't think.
Oh,
but he said he liked him for awhile.
Just came out yesterday.
Oh,
this is yesterday.
So I was right for awhile.
There'd been boys until recently.
Oh,
you know what it is because Donald trump
put out this ridiculous video about our
toughest opponents and he showed Putin
to like doing judo throws and then he
showed you.
Just see that.
It's a hilarious video.
Play it because it's so stupid and it
shows Hillary barking like a dog.
It's really like.
I mean you can say it's defamation,
like he's doing this judo throw and he
shows isis and then he throws the
Democrats have the perfect answer,
but you don't see that.
But she's there making bark noises,
bark,
bark.
Make America great again.
See it here.
You'll hear the music.
She Isis,
and then the Democrats have the perfect.
How rude can you just do that at a keys?
Put fucking bark noises in her.
Did she actually make those noises?
Making it?
Yeah.
Oh,
well,
I guess you can put a little remix of
it.
I think when you're running for
president,
everything's fair game.
But I saw a video that I've reaped
tweeted today.
It's called 13 minutes of Hillary
Clinton lying that someone posted.
It's all her saying one thing and then
saying a completely different thing that
she's always stood for a completely
different thing she gets while they just
wanted to make it so
you could absorb it.
Yeah,
I'm sure you could get deep as an
Australian American politics is
hilarious and also really sad.
That's how we feel.
You guys think you're having an election
right now,
the rest of the world.
We're viewing this as
cutest and yeah,
you're not doing so well.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I think it's an asshole job and I think
only assholes want that job at this
point in time.
I think at one point in time do we.
Is that the real.
You're right,
you're right.
But it became that with special interest
groups,
with a corporate donations being
completely unrestricted.
Now corporations can kind of act as an
individual and they have the freedom to
act is insane.
And so it's become a money grab and
we're a real strange one.
So what interests me is these guys like
Bernie Sanders and Donald trump for two
different reasons.
Bernie Sanders,
because he's a socialist and he doesn't
want any buns money and he wants to take
down corporations and he wants everybody
to pay more money to their workers and
he wants free healthcare and free
education.
And he's an extreme lefty.
You No,
well hang on,
I've got to stop here.
I pay the rest of the world.
Bernie sanders would be slightly left.
Hillary Clinton would be probably right.
And Donald trump would be out of the
building on the righthand side.
Yes.
Because when you look at Europe,
Australia is not a great example at the
moment because we kind of following you
guys.
But when you look at Europe like yet
nearly all your candidates are right of
Santa,
even though the Democrats or whatever.
Um,
Bernie Sanders I've heard a little bit
about and some of the stuff I agree
with,
I must be too.
Yeah,
I do as well.
I agree with a lot of social stuff a
lot.
I agree with the minimum wage thing and
that's the one thing that I need a real
talk to her.
Like a real economist who's like a
centrist,
someone who has a real objective
perspective on it because a lot of
people just trying to like protect money
and they don't want.
They definitely don't want to pay more
to workers and don't want a minimum wage
should be 15 bucks an hour,
which we call a living minimum wage.
But what I agree with a lot of his stuff
as far as like people like just just
social issues,
you know,
his issues when it comes to the
legalization of recreational drugs is
issues when it comes to a lot of things
like education being far too expensive
and students being saddled down with
ridiculous amounts of debt before they
get out there.
Why can't we engineer a system where
reasonable healthcare is taken care of
for people with normal,
regular stuff.
There's no reason why you can't go to
the world is telling you it's true,
but I have friends that live in Canada
and their healthcare is atrocious.
The way they describe it,
this is from me personally from them and
there's more than one person.
They've had issues with needing surgery
and they have to wait a year and hip the
hip replacements and knee surgeries and
things along those lines where they're
just limping around for like a year
waiting to get in Canada,
but I can speak of Australia because we
have obviously very similar system.
Australia's fucking fan tastic by.
You don't have to wait out a whole.
Like I go into see a doctor in the
morning and I can have a cat scan in the
afternoon or what have you.
You need to.
If it's a knee reconstruction,
yeah.
You get put on the list.
You wait three months.
Three months is not bad because you.
You might wait three months in America.
Yeah,
like it's,
it's not that bad,
but if it's something a little
definitely more urgent.
You're in surgery that afternoon.
That's great.
And then also that's the public system.
We don't have a private system as well,
so I pay $600 a year,
which most Americans find amazing,
but at $600 a year and that means I have
a choice where I can go to the public or
the private hospital and so if I get
told her you've got to wait three
months,
I can go,
well I'll use the private health
insurance in Iran on Tuesday.
That's incredible.
Well,
you have a better system than apparently
what's been described to me about Canada
and England as well,
but I just.
Australia is just so great as far as
like the cities and the people like
Melbourne.
I was in Melbourne and I was like,
man,
I don't even think I want to leave.
Like I could live there.
Like Melbourne is fantastic,
but have the Australia though.
It's not about the cities.
It's about the outback.
It's about the Great Barrier Reef.
It's about the remote places.
That's the.
Yeah,
that's for you.
You're,
you're all about the places where you
can die.
Get killed by Tasmanian Shit.
Tigers and shit.
Well they're not really.
It's like a dog,
right?
Task,
testimonial,
togare Gypsy that moving,
um,
where um,
what's his face?
Willem defoe goes and hunts.
The last one finds a Tasmanian Tiger and
hunted.
I missed that one stupid movie.
It's,
it's,
it seemed like a good idea.
But then you watch it.
It's really goofy.
And then the Tasmanian tiger,
obviously they're extinct.
So it's a,
it's a very like CGI,
Tasmanian Tiger.
Yeah.
Like the remember the lions in a.
I am legend Gooey.
It.
That would be like what?
That's how the Tasmanian Tiger looks
this?
Yeah,
there it is.
The hunter.
Yeah.
For some reason he was hired.
I don't remember the premise defoe.
So I'm kind of interested in yet at the
same time.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I mean,
well the outback is.
So the thing about Australia that's
fascinating to me is how few people
there are,
but yet how enormous the,
the actual country.
It's huge.
It's the size of Europe.
It's the size of a continental USA.
It's huge.
And there's only a 20 something million
people in the entire country when he.
What are we up to?
Twenty four now.
Somewhere.
That's Los Angeles.
Yeah.
We've got some big deserts and stuff
that we've got a lot of big space that's
not really that great.
I'm not habitable.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
we got some.
We don't have too many people and we've
sold immigration not completely,
so we don't have any refugee problem or
anything like that.
Really.
Yeah,
we sold it.
When we solved it solved.
How do you solve it?
Oh,
very,
very simple to a trump like wall.
Well,
we,
we've got an notion so we use that.
Um,
so when people come across on boats,
uh,
refugee boats,
you know,
jam packed full of people coming across.
We meet them with a postcard and then we
turn them around and then if they don't
turn around then we get all the people
on a coast guard,
military boats and then we take them to
another country,
to a detention camp and then we put them
in there.
Whoa.
If you're a reporter or maybe you with
Red Cross or something and you go visit
these dental detention camps,
you can get,
get put in jail for,
Oh God.
Ten years
or something for reporting on anything
that's going on there.
So totally we've solved the problem
because you can't report on it and yeah,
that seems a little fucked up,
isn't it?
We,
you know how you had George W Bush.
We had our own little George W dot Bush
a few years ago.
His name was Tony Abbott and he,
um,
he was messed up.
He messed up.
This is all his policies.
Yeah.
This is all his policy because he came
into power going,
well,
I'm going to stop the boats.
And so that's how he did it.
He just shipped him off to Papua New
Guinea to other countries and then made
it a punishable by two years in jail to
report anything about it.
Wow.
It's crazy.
That's insane.
But we solved the problem.
Well,
I guess you could say that,
but that sounds like how trump would do
it.
Yeah.
It's so,
like you're saying that trump is right,
you know,
way off the charts.
Right.
It sounds like your old president.
Yeah.
It's what I hate about it other than
it's just terrible for the people
involved is that we've lost our moral
standing.
We can't turn around and go,
Oh,
you know,
China,
you'll,
you'll doing this,
that the other four,
you know,
I've lost the word,
but you know,
we don't have that authority to have
that high stance anymore because we
messed up stuff to people as well.
Yeah.
And still going on to this day,
no way.
You will not make Australia home.
What is that?
Is that was that campaign.
Holy Shit Man.
But I bet you let some nice white people
and I know my friends that are comedians
that have moved there,
that they love it there.
My friend,
arch barker,
he's gigantic over there.
He became a huge,
huge star in Australia.
Yeah,
he's,
I mean I've watched quite a few of his
shows in Australia.
Yeah.
Funny Man.
Funny,
very funny.
But I mean,
what's interesting is he kind of just,
he's a regular comic here.
Like,
you know,
he's like a Tony Hinchcliffe or you
know,
a guy who does well,
he headlines and clubs over there.
He's a superstar,
like when I was over there,
like the first time I went to Sydney and
met people and they.
What do you do?
I'm a standup comedian.
Do you judge Barker everybody?
Is that a bad accident?
That's probably bad.
Next you're going to be throwing shrimp
on the Barbie or something?
No,
I wouldn't go that far man.
I'm not,
I'm not like that.
Um,
but anyway,
Australia is awesome.
So it seems like a really good place
though to have a base if you want to
explore like if you're from that part of
the world.
I have a friend,
my friend Adam Green tree lives out in
Australia and he's a bow hunter and he's
just constantly taking these incredible.
He's a great photographer as well and he
has these incredible photographs on his
website and I was blog.
He pulls up on those up.
You could see him,
but he um,
Adam Green tree and he's just constantly
and he's got this Toyota that he had
specifically set up for expeditions.
I can like live out of it for like
weeks.
You know,
most Australians have that setup.
Most
Australians have some camping setup for
a month,
you know,
out of their truck.
I saw a lot of those like snorkels and
stuff like they were super cool.
Yeah,
I mean you got some stretches in the
outback there where you can literally go
for 500 kilometers without a fuel
station,
so you've got to take extra fuel.
You've got to.
You got to be prepared.
Yeah.
They have those jerry cans that they
strap up to the roof of the car,
these gigantic jugs of gasoline,
and you just illustrate the real.
I put that out enough like everyone goes
to.
I'd been to Australia,
I've been to Sydney.
I'm like,
no,
you went to a nice city.
The Real Australia is where I'm from.
Cannes,
you know up the North East corner where
you've got rain forest and you've got a
great barrier reef and you've got the
outback and that sort of stuff.
The thing,
there's the oldest evidence of life ever
is on earth in Australia.
There was an ancient ancient reef.
There's Adams.
Sam Adams photos is one of them.
We've got some amazing photos that he's
taken.
Please go to.
He's got a website,
a really cool,
um,
but my oldest,
you talk in the human habitation,
no,
not human biological life.
There's some sort of a enormous reef
that they found in Australia that was
just fucking billions of years old.
I mean,
I do these two is where I first started
with linblad.
National Geographic was in the Kimberley
region of Australia,
which is the kind of northwest corner,
incredibly remote,
you know,
100 kilometers to the nearest road,
wherever you go,
you can only access it via these kind of
ships.
That's one way you can get there.
And you know,
you'll be cruising through 100 meter,
high,
300 foot.
So I'm a sandstone canyons and the
rocks,
there are one point 8 billion years old.
They predate fossils and that's the
Kenyans that you're cruising through the
whole.
It blows your mind to see that kind of
stuff.
And then up there as well as the oldest
human habitation.
And now that's looking at about.
Well there's still,
the data is still coming in,
but about 50,000
years old.
So the,
where human habitation on earth,
uh,
that's definitely in Australia,
in the Kimberley there.
I'm not sure that I'm older than Africa.
Well,
aboriginal people,
the native people,
they came into Australia once again,
lots of people very the numbers on this
but about 60,
70,000
years ago.
So that's when they entered into
Australia.
Um,
so they've been there for a long time,
very,
very long time and they're at work.
They're just will blow you away.
Right.
But obviously people were,
they,
they existed in Africa earlier than
that.
Homo sapiens sapiens.
You're talking about 200,000
years ago.
They,
that the species,
our species kind of evolved out of
Africa probably around Kenya,
somewhere around there.
And then we started migration.
Um,
and so we followed the coast,
which makes sense.
Most of our food was in the intertidal
zone.
That's where our food was.
So we followed the coast.
And so you go around basically Middle
East all the way down into Indonesia and
then across the short canoe ride,
probably the first,
the first ocean crossing into Australia.
And that's about it.
Yeah.
They think 70,000,
60,000
years ago.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's a that culture's been there for a
long time and there's a lot we can learn
from aboriginal people.
In fact,
there's a lot of good,
lots of interesting stuff.
Another horrible human rights violation
that you guys did.
Store aboriginal kids.
The empire strikes again,
started to raise them.
Yeah,
we did some.
We did some saying we you and I didn't
kill any sharp.
Didn't do it and steal any aboriginal
babies who can't keep saying we.
Well,
I'm part of humanity,
you know?
Yes.
A little bit of blind for it.
Oh,
I don't know about blame,
but we're,
we're a part of the race that has done
some fucked up shit,
but as also created cell phones.
Well,
that pool,
that's all forgiven then.
Real planes.
No,
not forgiven,
but you know,
it's sort of like your perspective thing
when you talking about sharks.
Yeah.
You gotta put it into perspective.
How many people have actually stole
aboriginal babies?
You know,
when you look at the billions of people
in the entire planet,
very few have actually done that.
Native cultures have had a really hard
hard truck and they have and if aliens
landed we'd have a hard time and so
that's how it always is.
The most technologically advanced
society thinks when it finds some sort
of a native society that's living in a,
a way that they used to live a long time
ago.
Like,
Oh,
you fuckers,
you don't even know what you're doing
yet.
Like you got to figure out this whole
wheel gun thing.
So this whole,
you know,
they were living sustainably and
environment for them 70,000
years and not,
you know,
not doing anything basically wrong or
harming that environment at any stage.
And then,
you know,
we know better.
Yeah.
That's how we think,
I guess.
But I mean,
we definitely shouldn't do that,
but I don't want to live on horseback
and chase buffalo with a stick.
I mean,
you hear this,
everyone thinks that doing something
about climate change or environment or
something is gonna make a reduction in
your,
your living.
Oh,
that's a totally different argument.
I'm talking about invading into places
where people are living.
You know,
this digitas lifestyle.
Like,
this is an issue,
they have them right now in the Amazon.
These tribes that are essentially
completely they,
they're almost non influenced by Western
civilization,
but I mean when you come to like
changing lifestyle and things to make up
for what we're doing to the environment.
Yeah.
No arguments here.
This is obviously some shit going down.
Oh yeah.
It's a little warm out.
Lately.
It was a little warm at lately.
Last month.
What was it?
The northern hemisphere two degrees
above industrial times Celsius is.
It's interesting.
You know I'm better than cooling though.
Cooling is much more terrifying.
Global Cooling is horrifying.
That's when populations dropoff.
That's when innovation drops off.
That's when it gets really scary.
I would say the warming since going to
be just as bad.
Have you ever read any of the work or
listened to any of the work by Randall
Carlson is a fascinating,
fascinating,
but I can't recall.
It's been on the podcast several times.
Maybe you've heard them.
They're it with Graham Hancock as well,
but he's an expert in impacts and
asteroid impacts.
Oh yes.
Okay.
He was doing this stuff out of Utah or
whatever,
all the glacial thing and he's basically
taken his entire life studying both
climate change that,
you know,
prehistoric climate change,
climate change,
but within the last ice age until now,
and connecting some of the climate
change,
some of it with a impacts with
asteroidal impacts at the end of the ice
age,
which is,
you know,
10 plus down.
Why would it not like,
well there's evidence,
actual evidence of impacts and,
and,
and um,
what they call nuclear,
a nuclear glass,
I think it's called [inaudible] night
and it's from a,
you get it when they do nuclear test
sites,
they find it and you also get it from a
meteor impact sites and it's just like
really cool looking green glass where
the ground understands.
Tend to.
Yeah.
But it's all over Europe and Asia and
around 12,000
years and they are pointing to that as
evidence of a massive impacts.
Like we got hit by everyone.
I mean,
the,
the layman always goes,
oh,
the last unit,
big impact 65 million years ago,
you know,
the kt boundary with dinosaurs and stuff
like that.
There has been impacts constant since
then and uh,
and this,
we just need more evidence basically to
fill in the gaps,
but there's been a lot of impacts.
We,
it wouldn't surprise me in our lifetime
that we see an impact.
Yeah,
we will.
Well,
we certainly have on other planets.
We saw a giant one on Jupiter that was,
that was crazy.
Oh my God.
She Maka leave it.
Yeah.
Yes.
Shoemaker Levy was as large as the
entire planet earth.
That's how big the impact was.
Well,
not the rock itself.
The impact of the implosion was as large
as the planet earth.
Apparently that's the place to use your
budget.
Maybe.
Maybe,
you know.
Yeah.
It's come a bit of space.
Defensive.
Yeah.
I hope they can figure that out.
We'll think about it.
We probably the first species on this
planet to ever get to the point where we
could we have the technology to defend
the planet from these cataclysmic events
were the first people to have that
ability,
but we're not using it well.
We're the first people to come close to
having that ability.
I think they have some inkling as to how
to do that right now.
Like a coating them with some sort of a,
a silicone or something like that.
For whites.
You nudge them and nudge them is easiest
way.
You just go land something on them with
a rocket on it and then stopped burning
that rocket and if you do it early
enough you will change the trajectory
enough to see this so many of them.
That's part of the problem,
right?
There's like $900,000
year herth objects.
Yeah,
but it's within our power.
We can do it and it's crazy that we're
not because really that's,
that's something can really mess
up society that we currently have.
That's a nice way of putting it.
Mess Up.
Yeah.
Maybe Australia be the spot.
Well,
you guys have been hit too.
That was one of the things that Randall
concentrated on.
He showed these slides last time he was
here maybe the time before that where he
showed these massive tsunami erosion
marks all over this one area of
Australia,
which indicate there was something that
landed in the ocean off the coast and
just caused massive,
massive tidal waves.
I think he was saying,
if I remember correctly,
somewhere around 6,000
plus years ago.
Yeah.
But
those tidal waves from earthquakes,
you know,
you don't even have to have an impact
against an army coming in and the
tsunami,
if you don't remember the one sort of in
Indonesia and stuff like that.
And Sri Lanka liked it can do a lot of
damage.
You know,
I was looking at your notes,
man.
Did you see a Ufo?
I,
I think so.
Well it's a flying
object.
Yes I did.
Was it little aliens in green men?
I'm not too sure on that one.
Um,
do you think it might've been need more
evidence?
Um,
where was it?
So I spent a lot of time on boats when I
was growing up,
you know,
so I would spend months or months added,
see,
and uh,
so I'd regularly,
you know,
be in the middle of nowhere,
thousand kilometers from the nearest
town,
a light source.
And so you'd go out middle of the night,
go to the toilet,
a toilet on a boat is basically go over
to the side,
hang,
hanging over the railing.
And uh,
and so you look at these stats like and
there you see this,
you see satellites,
you see,
you know,
the most,
most people I don't think even have ever
seen the amount of stars you can get
when you get to a very remote location
to the point where you see individual
satellites going over and stuff like
that.
And so that's what I grew up doing most
nights,
you know,
I would be sitting there and looking at
this and once or twice I did see some
stuff that you go hang on and being a
bit of a bit of an aviation buff,
I love sort of space and aviation go,
hang on,
that's not quite right.
That doesn't make sense of how that
object went that way.
And then turned around and went the
other way.
How old were you?
Oh,
we were talking between 10 to 15,
somewhere in there.
My memory between that age is dog shit.
But it was more than one on one
occasion,
but we're in the middle of nowhere.
Like we were literally,
if there was ever,
if you're doing a secret military,
which a plane flight or something,
that would be the place to do it because
we're in the middle of nowhere.
And what did you say?
What did you do?
I'm seeing some,
some big lights,
uh,
going to slow a fair distance.
Why?
Nothing over and over I think.
But you know,
going off into the distance.
And then I remember seeing one time
where I went out there and started doing
my thing and then I saw a light that
looked like,
you know,
Venus,
like a bright star.
I'm like,
hmm,
that's interesting.
Bit light for Venus to be up because
normally Venus's right at the start,
sunset sunrise.
So I think it's a bit strange.
And then you know,
and then you look back and it's moved
and then hang on and then you try and
work it out with the boat moving and
stuff like that.
And then it just started
to move and then turn around and move
the other way.
And it's just like my,
from my knowledge of aviation,
it's like,
eh,
there's nothing really.
They can do that.
So what it was,
who knows?
But I just,
I find the whole thing fascinating.
I find it interesting.
Yeah.
I think I.
well first of all,
I want to believe so bad.
I always have,
from the time I was a child and I think
many people share that romantic notion
of how amazing it would be if we were
visited by some intelligent life.
We're not aliens and it's a big waste of
space.
Well,
the most likely is something alive out
there.
The question is whether or not it's
visiting us.
Yeah,
and if it did visit us,
it would have to be so far removed from
what we think is possible and as far as
like technology,
but we also,
I think part of what's going on with our
own minds when we consider the future,
so we know that technology keeps
improving,
we keep innovating,
we keep coming up with new methods for
all sorts of different things and one
day we're most likely going to be able
to regularly journey to other parts of
the universe.
Most likely if we raised NASA's budget
slightly,
well,
nothing new.
Well I think private sector is probably
the best option.
I mean when when people start finding
profit in visiting,
I mean if they can figure out how to
mine for diamonds,
is there like one of Jupiter's moons or
something like that?
It's made out of fucking diamonds,
like moments.
It's actually another planet they found
out in the like one of the newly
discovered planets.
Planets,
if you find that there's a fucking
planet made out of diamonds out there,
well we think based on looking at
wavelengths of light coming from
hundreds of light years away.
Not really.
We.
Sorry,
could you get it here?
It is.
Language.
Yeah.
English is a astronomers discover a
planet made of diamonds.
Jesus called riced racing around a tiny
star and our galactic backyard,
so if they could figure out how to visit
that they had below a fuck.
First of all,
diamonds would be worth like a dollar.
Well,
I mean that whole gravity waves thing
is,
is a great step forward.
Then suddenly we are seeing that you can
adjust gravity.
Gravity is adjustable to a certain
degree.
That's probably where the interstellar
technology will come from.
More research into that area and the
fact that we just kind of.
We.
They just proved that concept that they
sort of bastardized in the event
horizon.
You ever seen that movie where they talk
about folding space time and punching a
hole through the two points,
so you would surmount.
You would rather you would traverse
insurmountable distances and a very
short period of time.
My understanding is that's wound whole
log where with the gravity waves it's
probably star trek does it well
enterprise where you basically,
you're just adjusting this,
the fabric of space time in front and
behind the ship and so
you're not moving faster than the speed
of light.
You're just kind of making a bubble in
the space time that you then traveling.
Um,
it's fascinating when you read right
into it and I think that's probably
where it'll come from.
But yeah,
we need a lot more studying on that one.
Yeah,
you think you'll get there.
But we will.
I mean if we,
if humans survive 100,000
years,
I mean imagine.
And that's the concept.
The concept is if there is some life
form out there,
we've been alive or this planet rather
has been around for four point something
billion years.
So if something just had a different
combination of elements and maybe
perhaps lives in a protected area where
they don't have a gigantic asteroid
field just outside of distance between
Mars and Jupiter,
you know,
like we do or I mean there's only,
there's comments and they might live in
some protected area where they have more
freedom to,
uh,
to grow and innovate.
And we're in a goldilocks zone if you
really look into it.
Like for us,
we totally,
Nicole,
it looks on the moon,
right?
But you know,
the dinosaurs is only 65 million years
ago got completely fucking smashed by a
rock like that could happen.
You know,
and you know,
the big crater outside Nevada like
these,
there's so many of them that could mean
that it is possible though,
that there is a source system out there
that doesn't have this issue,
that for whatever reason doesn't have
nearly as many asteroids.
And so some life form has been
innovating for millions of years more
than us.
But that is when we can do that right
now.
That's what I'm saying.
We have the technology right now to stop
these cataclysmic impacts.
I think you're being a little.
I didn't say this.
I think they miss a lot of them,
a good percentage of them because of the
gravity and the way the sun is and the
sun is so fucking massive,
a million times larger than the earth
that I think when things are coming
behind the sun,
oftentimes they don't even see them
until it's too late and until we could
figure that out and you've got these
fucking Manhattan sized chunks or rock
for in our way,
I think a one day maybe we'll be able to
do it,
but my point being that it is possible
that there's some sort of a civilization
out there that doesn't have to deal with
impacts that may be maybe they've
developed in a way that they don't have
predators the way we do.
They haven't.
They don't have this need for,
for warfare the way that we do.
Maybe they have some unique method of
communication that allows for more
understanding than just mouth noises.
Well,
I mean,
I wouldn't say it's a need,
but it is.
It is prevalent throughout history,
so it seems to be a part of humans.
It's.
It's arguable that we can move past it
for sure,
and I certainly hope we can.
Obviously we can.
We can do it in small groups.
We can do it in cities.
We can do,
but war has existed as long as humans
have existed.
So you would say if you were studying
human beings objectively,
not idealistically,
not,
not looking at things through rose
colored glasses,
you would say,
well,
this is what humans do.
It's one of the things they do.
You know,
if you were studying us as an animal,
if you were some species from another
planet,
you'd say,
well,
they do shoot each other a lot as a
collective group.
Yes.
Go to the individual level.
And I think,
yeah,
I think the opinion is totally
different.
You go to an individual,
they don't want to kill other people.
It's in human nature.
We don't want to kill other people.
Right.
But I mean it just objective.
I mean,
it's sort of like the way you look at
sharks,
you know,
and you look at sharks,
you say,
well,
you know,
they only kill five of us a year,
so you know,
really they're harmless.
Well,
they are kind of harmless them to one of
them fucking bites you,
you know.
And that's sort of the same way about
people.
Yes,
most of the time humans are wonderful.
Most of the Times people are like,
you and I have a drink,
we clink glasses,
we enjoy our company,
we have a great chat and that's most of
the interactions you're ever going to
have with people are great most,
most times,
like the vast majority of interactions
you have,
especially in America where there's
plenty of food,
there's plenty of space and people are
well taken care of.
Most of the time everything's gonna be
great,
but when you tally up the numbers for 7
billion people and then the battle for
natural resources and then religious
ideologies come into play and there's a
lot of fucking killing going on
constantly.
You know,
I mean,
so it's,
it's an unavoidable.
I mean,
you could certainly make the argument
that we can do better,
but if you just want it to look at us
right now,
just know ideology attached.
Just look at what a human being is.
Human beings killed.
We're killing all over the place.
We're killing each other all over the
place.
It's just happening right now as we're
talking.
There's people shooting people is bombs
going off and people killing themselves
as it's going on.
So it's.
It is a part of human beings that we
have,
we have come to accept,
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
other life forms have this,
you know?
I mean there it is potentially possible
to wasted resources.
Any evolved alien that we've ever
encountered.
I would say very unlikely that they
would do will fit because it's just such
a waste of resources.
It's.
Yeah.
How do you get to interstellar travel?
If you spending all your money working
on new ways to kill each other,
it just,
it doesn't work well.
Also like what's the benefit of it?
Like what is the benefit of it?
The benefit of it is all personal.
It's all like a whatever group gets to
dominate the resources,
whatever group gets to,
you know,
maybe their,
their genetics pass on Gangam style,
whereas the,
the,
the people that were dominated,
they don't get to it.
It's all very primitive and a lot of
ways.
It's very animalistic.
The biggest Dick Syndrome now in some
way.
Yeah,
it's a genetic thing,
right.
But if we get past that,
like one of the weirder things in Ufo
folklore is the idea of genetic
manipulation.
The idea that human beings have been
created by which the lady six files
video.
No,
I did not.
I haven't seen the new x files.
Is it good?
Is it on Fox again?
Um,
I don't even know.
What time is it now?
I think it's great that they're doing it
again.
I probably should watch it.
It's like the old one.
The reason I bring it up is because
that's pretty much what the last two
episodes is all about.
What's going on and on about that.
Well,
that's a big theme
in Ufo Folk Lore and also in Zechariah
sections work.
Do you know about that guy?
Once again?
Heard of him to,
I don't think about anything.
He's just a guy who was a biblical
scholar and a linguist and he knew a lot
about ancient languages and he had a
very controversial,
uh,
he,
he did.
What he did is he went over the Sumerian
texts,
the cuneiform clay tablets with the
weird lines and,
and what he came up with.
And really,
he's like the only one out of all the
other Sumerian scholars.
He believes that the Annunaki which are
descriptive depicted in these ancient
Sumerian texts.
He believe it was an ancient.
He believed it was an ancient
civilization of aliens that came down
here.
And their planet is in an elliptical
orbit.
The travels between Mars and Jupiter.
Yeah,
exactly.
Which they now think is they now think
there is a planet out there and they
don't know out.
Yes.
Yeah.
They don't necessarily think it's a new
bureau,
which is what he called it and what they
called it in the text,
but his,
his,
um,
deciphering of the Sumerian Texas,
hugely controversial.
And there's a website actually called
Sitchin is wrong.
And if you go to in Israel,
I think it's dot com might be.org,
but if you go to switch and is wrong,
they sort of highlight all the errors
that they believe he made,
but it's so convoluted like you have to
be some sort of a scholar to even
understand the argument and you have to
understand cuneiform that weird writing
with a little lines and,
but the,
um,
some of the ancient clay tablets,
forget about understanding the language.
The ancient clay tablets are
fascinating.
I mean they had a,
an exact description of the solar
system,
a drawing of all the planets in the
proper order with the proper sizes.
And this is 6,000
years ago,
including Pluto.
Ancient culture is amazing.
And I think it was probably when I first
started listening to you is the
interview with Graham Hancock.
It was just such a big fan.
I've read all his books,
love him to death.
And uh,
and I remember reading his books,
you know,
back in the day called whatever it was,
early nineties or something.
And reading.
Yeah,
anxious.
And it just made sense to me that there
is lots of ancient civilizations going
way back and the evidence is everywhere.
You just have to open your eyes a little
bit to it.
And you know,
I love that.
Back then in the nineties it was
pseudoscience.
Today it's like,
yeah,
of course,
of course there's lots of ancient
civilizations and we just need to find
more and more.
And I think one of the best ones is,
did you ever hear about in Egypt?
You know,
because they uncover.
So Lula nature,
there's so much more they see the new
stuff that I sold that two days ago.
No,
no,
not the lightest.
They believe they found Nefertiti's tomb
who they found they found two hidden
tombs in Egypt than they believe they
might have located where she was buried.
You see that Jamie?
I
retweeted it like two days,
like maybe yesterday.
I think what I find it in King Tut's
tomb,
90 percent chance of hidden chambers.
And I think it's an effort tds resting
place.
Fucking quarter.
I was getting at is that this
researcher,
she took the data from satellites,
ground penetrating radar.
Oh,
sorry,
yeah.
Do you see that documentary?
Fascinating and they're just shows that
the whole of Egypt was just covered in
these terms underground.
They're everywhere and there's so much
more information and the more research
we do,
we're going to find out as ancient
civilizations going way,
way back.
I mean,
I don't know,
Egypt very well,
never been,
but in Australia,
in the Kimberley,
there's this two types of artwork.
Then there's this one which is from the
aboriginal people that live there and
it's been going on for a couple thousand
years.
Then there's this other artwork called
the bradshaw or going on going on and we
know it's over 30,000
years old,
but really it could be a lot,
lot further,
so it's from a group of people who were
in Australia before the aboriginal and
you look at some of these pitches and
they're amazing,
amazingly intricate and you can't even
see the joker anymore.
There's no paint anymore.
It's just the shadow of where the paint
was.
That's what you're actually viewing
because it's so old,
so they can't actually carbon date it.
They just look at say a wasp nest grows
on top of it and then the carbon date
that.
So they go,
okay,
well it's older than the wasp nest and
so we're talking around about 30,000,
probably a bit more,
but some of his artwork is crazy and
I've.
I've never seen it personally but there
is one out there drawing which basically
has pictures of these,
you know,
the people who have to go and go and
brad short people these long really
skinny long sort of people.
There's one with a Ufo in it as well and
intricate drawings of all the animals
that were there and it's fascinating
stuff and once again one guy did a lot
of research and he,
a lot of his research still hasn't been
released of where it all is and what's
going on.
There is literally everywhere you walk
up there,
there's this ancient,
ancient our.
It's crazy and it's from a culture that
is very,
very old.
Probably 30 to 50,000
in my opinion.
The data suggest over over 25,000
years ago.
That's so fascinating to me.
Just when you were talking about going
through those canyons and it's one point
8 billion years old that the amount of
time this sort of impossible to grasp
distance in time,
it's,
it's we in our mind,
we just can't.
It's just we just can't.
And so that when you think about that,
like this insurmountable amount of time
and then think about like just 30,000
years ago,
which is still insurmountable.
I mean we think of about $30,000
in comparison to one point 8 billion not
that long ago,
but it's impossible.
You,
your mind is not going to get it.
It's a number.
It's like I have $30,000
like that.
You understand?
You make $30,000,
you understand $30,000,
you don't understand 30,000
years.
It just not to get in there.
At least my,
my comprehension for you,
you just can't even comprehend it.
But the Graham Hancock stuff combined
with the Randall Carlson stuff is to me
where it all sort of comes together
because Randall Carlson offers an
explanation for these.
These civilizations being so advanced
but yet all essentially wiped out,
just rising sea levels can explain that
so many people don't know that the sea
level was about 150 meters lower than it
is today.
Um,
and so all these civilizations,
civilizations are always put on the
coast,
so you're right on the coast.
Massive amount of people and suddenly a
hundred and 50 meters of waters there.
There is so much that we still discover
on our coast in 150 meters of water.
There will be lots and lots of evidence
down there,
but it gets covered in silt within a
thousand years and it's hard to find
someday they're going to find Miami.
They're going to find my.
They go,
what the hell happened here?
Jesus Christ,
just bags of coke and fake tits.
They're just going to find like
stilettos Ferrari's under water.
I liked that as a thought experiment of
go forward 10,000
years and be a geologist looking back at
our little timeframe here,
the anthropocene or whatever you want to
call them,
where humans have been impacting the
planet like that layer of rock.
What are you going to find in it?
I found that interesting.
What do you think is going to be there?
They're going to find those kettlebells
behind you.
The Werewolf one.
You're going to fuck with these people
doing.
They're going to find,
well,
you're going to find only stone.
Really,
essentially.
I mean,
have you ever seen that?
Um,
uh,
there was a documentary that they did
where they showed what would happen
within a thousand years if we just
abandoned cities.
Like what would happen?
How could you have to take into
documentary series?
That was it.
Yeah.
Amazing,
right?
Yeah.
Well there's some photos of Detroit.
It's really interesting how nature is
taking over buildings in Detroit.
Like trees are growing through the
center of houses and it's just only
within a few decades,
the main source of erosion in the
kimberleys and stuff like that is
plants.
And so in the,
in the dry season,
they grow into the cracks and stuff.
That routes.
And then in the wet season,
they resemble this water and their route
swell and exerts a pressure about,
I think that 3000 psi,
it just literally just cracks it.
And that happens to concrete if you're
not constantly pulling that,
all those grass seeds and making sure
stuff isn't growing around concrete,
all our infrastructure will be crumbled
and very little left just by plants are
amazing.
Yeah.
I pulled the wire and pull it.
I had a problem my toilet and put this
on Instagram,
find that,
that toilet monster.
So,
uh,
I had the guy come over the plumber guy
and just doesn't flush.
I don't know what's going on.
So he was like a snake that has a camera
on it and they find that there was a
crack in the pipe and the roots had gone
through the small crack in the pipe,
gotten inside the toilet pipe and filled
the entire pipe with a root system.
I mean it looked like an animal.
I mean we're talking about something
that was like four plus feet long.
Enormous look it,
leave that up there.
They pulled that out of my toilet.
And then it's saying,
yeah,
but does it surprise me?
Doesn't surprise me there now,
but back then I was like,
what the fuck?
They will be.
I mean that life after people,
you watch that thing,
they get to 100 years and you barely
recognize the city 100 years later.
Yeah,
there's some plans.
There's some cool photos of in Detroit.
Look at that photo of this.
These houses that are just being taken
over by trees.
That's the center of a house.
It just trees grow in the middle of it.
They burst through the foundation,
they break through the bottom floors.
They go through the ceiling,
they fill up.
Look at that house.
Yeah.
Well this is something that we were
talking about before we started the
show.
You were talking about being in Costa
Rica and these people see what you would
call like Phantom Pyramids.
They think people always want to.
They.
It's very beneficial to find ancient
structure.
So there's a.
there's a few ancient structures
throughout the world that are extremely
controversial because people look at
them and they go,
well then another say yard.
Dang.
That's like A.
Essentially it's a structure that is
just a natural structure that you're
trying to attribute to a civilization.
Well,
there's enough ancient structures out
there to be amazed.
Let's just put that forth.
Like you don't need to find hundreds of
them.
The the,
the 20 or 30 that we have is amazing.
Right.
But we like finding them in our yard.
Yeah.
I was a cheer Polo if you ever heard of
that.
That's where I went.
And Costa Rica.
I was visiting my cousin down there and
a vibe.
I just got to put that out there.
Like when you're up in the mountains
there.
I had a little Sabina on the top of a
ridge looking over this massive valley
and the vibe and the like.
It's just phenomenal because the
indigenous people there are still
relatively in touch with the natural
environment and there's large areas here
with me as a gringo.
I can't go.
I can't go anywhere near it.
I'm only the.
The indigenous people there and people
look at satellite maps and they go,
yeah,
this is one massive pyramid.
The largest pyramid in the world could
also just be a mountain as well.
Like I'm all about evidence.
Show me the evidence and um,
I've got an open mind.
I'm happy I do.
They think it's the largest pyramid
normal just by.
If you look at the satellite data and
then draw it out,
it would be the largest pyramid in the
world.
Right?
But what makes them think that it's a
pyramid shape and stuff like that?
Yeah,
I,
that's it right there.
That's a fucking mountain bitch you get
out of here.
So that's ridiculous.
Well,
there's actually a dance where I live,
there's a place called Walters pyramid
and there is actually this Little Hill
Mountain,
whatever you want that's in the shape of
a pyramid perfectly.
And this,
it's in Cannes called Walsh's pyramid.
People run up and down it all the time.
There's a big fitness thing for it's,
you know,
and that's pretty much a pyramid,
but it's just a,
it's just a natural formation.
So it's not a pyramid,
but that mountain is a mountain.
It's like saying the earth is the
biggest soccer ball in the world.
I mean,
it kind of is.
If we were big enough to kick it.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
but it's,
it's the earth.
We found a huge ball.
It's 24,000
miles in a circle and you're standing on
it.
As I said before,
the show to Costa Rica.
This is so crazy.
People down there.
Look,
I've got an open mind.
I'm willing to listen to people,
but uh,
yeah,
show me the evidence.
There's a way that you can get
when you party too much,
where your grasp on reality is like
holding onto a dolphin with olive oil on
your hands and you just,
you just can't quite grasp it.
And I've met a lot of people like that.
All,
lot of people like that because of my
reputation within a,
you know,
quote unquote psychedelic community and
my connections to marijuana on
psychedelic drugs and all that stuff.
I've met so many I've met before I go
negative,
amazing people.
I've met some really fascinating
openminded people that have Dennis
Mckenna,
the Lorenzo haggerty.
I met some amazing people,
but I've also met some,
like some people that they've lost their
ability to discern what might be
possible versus what you're adding to
all this stuff to make it more fantastic
than it really is.
And,
and by doing so,
you're,
you've entered into this sort of fantasy
land and you've sort of negated all
potential realistic,
uh,
interpretations of.
Yeah.
When I meet people at that,
and I do too,
I always push them towards them saying,
okay,
so you've read these books now,
now going to read a physics textbook and
just get all your information.
Then make your own opinions,
your opinion.
Well,
you're dealing with more high level
people.
You're dealing with book readers.
I'm dealing with youtube watchers,
man.
I am really lucky to new into a youtube
video about reptilians.
Don't be so quick to dismiss them,
brother.
There are amongst.
So I'm very lucky that in my job and I
guess the brand national geographic as
well,
it brings in people who are progressive
nature lovers,
chimney rather intelligent.
I have dinner with these people and
that's probably the biggest perks for me
is you meet people who are just
fascinating because they always attack
you with questions,
so you spend half the meal just
answering questions like we're doing now
kind of thing,
and then then eventually turn around and
go,
well,
what do you do?
And generally the graduates of Harvard
or mit and it's like,
what do you do?
Well,
on the International Space Station,
the little box that spins the solar
panels,
I invented that,
you know,
even some.
I met a,
I think it was the older George Bush,
George H,
w Bush,
his lawyer had some very pertinent
questions for him.
You just meet some really interesting
people that are kind of unknown I
suppose to a certain degree and just
hearing their opinions and their life
story.
It's fascinating.
People are fascinating.
Well,
it seems like being involved in national
geographic would make kind of like a
magnet for curiosity in the creek.
Curious people
just come to you and go,
Ooh,
that's as soon as you messaged me,
I was like,
Ooh,
this fucking guy's seen some shit.
Yep.
Yeah.
There's a lot of,
I've worked on other ships that don't
have the national geographic brand and
yet you still get 50 percent really
cool,
interesting people,
but then you get a group of people who
also aren't that interested in what's
going on and that's kind of a selling
point is that we have all these experts
on there.
I mean,
I wouldn't go so far.
It's called myself an expert,
but like we went to Easter island a
couple months ago and we had the world
expert on Easter island on board the
ship.
That was,
that was the guy that was living next
door to me.
That's the guy from your instagram page.
A.
Yeah.
Year.
Yes.
Last name.
How do you pronounce it?
Jamie?
Christiana crop on instagram.
Um,
his,
uh,
the photos of Easter island to me.
I am absolutely blown away by Easter
Island and perplexed and fascinated and,
and I always try to understand.
I'm like,
why would someone spend so much time to
make these statues and where are they
getting these stones from and like.
And they go deep,
deep,
deep into the ground.
Like when you go deeper into the ground,
you see that it's not just a head and
there's a whole body and a full figure
down there.
What do you mean or is that fake?
That's all those pictures where they dug
into the ground.
You see like this,
this shoulders and stuff like that.
They're not.
Well,
I suppose you could say that some of
them do have bodies.
Yes,
but most of the ones you see the most of
them are like that just to show most of
them,
but that's what you see.
But under the ground isn't there more?
I mean this is obviously a victim of
erosion,
right?
These things have been eroded by time
and wind and sand.
These ones actually they couldn't be
bothered moving them.
These are right.
The quarry,
this is where they've cut them out of
the side of the mountain.
This group right here and so and then
they haven't been bothered or whatever's
happened.
Haven't been bothered to move.
The cute doug who's doggy,
just random dog came up and set my
photos everywhere.
Really?
It was like a wild dog.
Yeah.
Just there's so many dogs on that island
and they're all so friendly and lovely
and I will as soon as I see that.
I know that's a good community.
One of the things for me straightaway
dog.
Yeah,
so I'm Jamie,
see if he could find those photos of
Easter island where they dig.
There's some expeditions that they've
done where they've dug out around the
statues and dug deep down and you could
see arms.
It's more than just ahead.
Well the one,
the photo that had on the instagram
there with Claudia,
she,
he's sitting next to you go to this
thing,
goes all the way down.
She his hands,
his arms,
the big one.
Yeah.
That's a big one,
but that's real,
right.
I personally didn't see that was from
the Ucla,
but there is what I was describing where
the one picture I have it.
Claudio.
He's got a whole heap that got knocked
over by a tsunami and he's put them back
up and they're full ones with.
They basically standing up with their
hands over their belly.
Yeah.
Like that.
So you have the.
Well,
with the top hat on top,
what is that?
One of the upper left Jamie with heads
about.
Yeah,
right
there.
What the hell is that?
That's fake,
right?
Right.
Yeah,
yeah.
Feel like yoga.
Don't get me wrong.
The first question,
when I got there,
the first question,
I was like bodies underneath and first
question,
but um,
they to help because they didn't want to
dig crazy.
Gringos sorts of politics always,
always with anything like this is their
crazy politics.
Is it hard when you go to these,
these communities because you want to
respect their cultures and their way,
but you also want to kind of get to the
bottom of these things as much as you
can in a brief amount of time.
I suppose.
How do I attack that one?
Um,
I,
I suppose when you get the expert on
board,
you know,
and then you get to hear about all these
sort of stuff.
But I guess most people going through
here wouldn't hear half the stuff that
we learn about because you don't have
that world experts sitting there.
You've got just some random two guide or
something like that.
So there's a lot to it and I know with
Claudio he had epic battles with the
alternate because he just wanted to
restore,
it was just a big pile of them piled up
and he wanted to come in here with a
crane and put them all back to how they
were and yeah,
the amount of flack and backlash and
trouble that he went through over,
I think it was more than five years to
do it.
So unfortunate.
But that happens in so many of these
places where they want to sort of
preserve the narrative,
like they have a narrative and they've
been,
you know,
giving these speeches and they have this
idea of a timeline,
how everything was done and when new
evidence comes along,
very,
very reluctant to accept it.
You find that a lot in Egypt.
Well,
I mean he's the guy that wrote 20 papers
about that particular narrative and
you've just come over and say,
oh actually that's all wrong.
Or different aspects of it.
Of course they're gonna bring it up and
it's a lot of pushback is the coolest
like that.
What I found very interesting about
Australia was the birdman culture.
Yes,
go into it though,
please.
So you've got this,
this culture with statues and stuff,
and then that culture actually kind of
died out,
but it definitely went out of favor and
then you had the birdman culture come
into it and that was the last one to be
there.
When you know,
at Western civilization kind of turned
up and that was crazy.
It was a competition every year where
they would all run,
swim out to another island,
down a steep cliff.
Holly would die in the process and try
and get the first egg,
basically the first egg from the turns
there and then have to bring it all the
way back in.
The first one back with his egg was then
the,
I guess some sort of analogy would be
Jesus basically,
but you know,
somewhere he's the God basically and,
and so,
but his manner,
his energy was then far too powerful for
anyone to have any contact with him.
So He's as winning his prize was he
would go live in a little hut by himself
for the rest of the year.
He wasn't allowed to cut his fingernails
or hear anything for a year and then
they can come back.
But his group,
his tribe would then be the leaders of
the island.
Okay.
So basically all the different groups
would.
Every year they're changeover who's in
control and that will keep everyone
happy.
So there wasn't one particular group
that was in charge of everything.
It,
it varied based on who won the Birdman
and competition that year,
how they came up with that.
I have no idea.
It's so bizarre.
There's so many weird styles of culture,
like the way people decide to run their
stuff.
Yeah.
So strange.
Like how the hell does that ever come
about where everyone agrees.
All right,
the dude who gets the egg,
you're Jesus,
you got to live by yourself.
So it's like I don't want to live by
myself and he probably doesn't want to
live by himself either.
So it's like a bittersweet victory.
A GAM Jesus.
But now I can't even cut my fingernails.
I got to live in a fucking hut by
myself,
but I'm full of so much manner.
Well,
there's so many really uber bizarre
cultural traditions all around the
world.
I'm sure you're aware of the semen
warriors in New Guinea semen.
Yes.
Now I've traveled extensively through
puppeting Guinea.
You'll have to enlighten.
Oh,
it's awful.
It's essentially a culture of child
molestation where they take children
from the time they're very young and
they moved them away from their mother
and they move into these bachelor groups
and they have these older men and these
younger boys and they essentially tell
these younger boys that the only way for
them to grow up and be strong,
and we're talking about a culture that
says thousands and thousands of members,
the only way for them to grow up and be
strong is to ingest semen so they have
to ingest it orally and annually and it
is a an ancient tradition of these semen
warriors in New Guinea and they have.
They've grown up being molested and then
molesting new children as they come up
and it's homosexual molestation and
stuff.
Yeah,
I mean it's.
This is documented,
this is not like something I'll make on
that
crazy stuff pumping to Guinea.
I spent a lot of time in asthma and
region,
which actually is in Papa New Guinea,
Indonesia,
but let's not go there.
You see anything about that Jamie?
Yeah.
I found something on wikipedia called
the Toro tribe.
It's really dark man.
They think it extended their life for
homosexual sex prolongs life and
heterosexual relationships are focused
towards reproduction.
Yeah.
And then also it makes the young men
strong.
They think the only way for them to grow
and become strong as by adjusting semen
only 20 years ago in the Hazmat region,
they were head hunters.
They were cannibals,
I mean end to say,
oh,
there's no cannibalism anymore is kind
of a bit of a lie as well.
There still cannibalism in Papa New
Guinea just deleted each other,
not out front row center,
but they keep it offline basically to
keep it off of youtube.
Um,
but yeah,
there's some crazy stuff going on there,
especially in the Hazmat region.
I spent quite a bit of time there and
what I find interesting is you got this
culture as old as the aboriginals in
Australia,
you know,
we're talking 60,000
years old,
very old culture,
living in perfect harmony nature in the
mangroves there and they're not even,
they're not even stone people that just
would.
People you know,
they don't even have anything and then
now you have,
it's,
it's an Indonesian province and you have
a lot of mosques being built and a lot
of stuff that's kind of creeping in.
Western civilization is creeping in and
the most disgusting thing I saw is that
they,
they've always gone down to the market
and bought some food and it's in wrapped
in banana leaf.
They eat the food and they throw the
banana leaf off the board,
walk into the water.
Now the mercantile empires now in there,
you know there's lots of other people,
a Chinese Japanese coming in and being
merchants and they sell everything in
plastic,
single use packets and so the same
thing.
There's no garbage bins,
there's nothing around.
They open it,
they eat the food,
they throw the plastic over there is a
meter and a half to two meters of just
piles of plastic everywhere.
Absolutely everywhere because they don't
have any ability that I've got no
education on it.
They've got no garbage collection and
it's bloody disgusting.
Like it's crazy that you go to a beach
scene in Australia and you'll see one or
two bits of plastic and like,
oh,
this is terrible.
When you pick it up,
you go there and you're like,
I need like 50 dump trucks to even get
it.
Stop on this.
The plastic problem in the ocean is huge
and it's not until you kind of get go
through Indonesia.
Even the Maldives Seychelles so much
plastic everywhere and it's like meter
high in places.
Heard the Maldives is one of the primary
groups of islands that are at risk of a
global warming of being.
The highest point on the capital in the
Maltese is two meters high.
Whoa.
Yeah.
When the tsunami in 2004 came,
it went over the entire island.
I think it was only a little tiny patch
that didn't have seawater go over it.
It's crazy.
I've got a picture on the instagram is
one of the first pictures ever put up
there.
All of the capital and you'll see it's
something like 250,000
people in a tiny little island and it's
shocking like there.
They're serious,
just pumped straight out.
There's another island next to it that's
the garbage island where they just take
all the garbage and burn it.
So it's this constant,
massive fire on the nearest island where
they just burn garbage.
It's environmental catastrophe
that went through that.
That's the Maldives?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
But this is Indonesia,
Papua New Guinea.
Like oh my God.
That picture.
So disturbing.
That first picture,
Jamie,
go back to that first one that you
posted.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That is God damned insane.
Yeah,
no,
they were on these tours and we would
actually spend the first hour before
guests come over just cleaning up
plastic and then the first guest to come
over with generally help us clean
plastics as well,
and we would take back 10,
20 bags of garbage just so you could
walk along a little bit of the beach and
not have plastic everywhere.
Oh my God.
That's horrible.
Wow.
When you,
when you see the sheer numbers game,
Jamie,
what was
your google search so people could check
out these images that are listening to
this plastic island?
Oh,
that's so horrific.
It's an entire island is just covered
with shit plastic.
Wow.
People are so quick and they're just
finding it.
That's the only way they can do anything
about it.
It was burning and that's the only
250,000
people.
Right?
Well that's the capital.
I'm leery of that.
Oh my God.
Jamie capital.
And I think it's one of the first images
that have.
Look at that photo of the capital.
Yeah.
I was cruising past and I,
I took a picture with a,
um,
with a drone at sunset and it's quite
pitcher.
I quite like it.
Um,
but you just see the amount of people
packed into this tiny little space and
they've just got,
they've got no means to recycle,
do anything about it.
It's,
and it's probably got a couple of
decades and then it'll be all those
people have to go somewhere else.
You know,
I always feel like I want to fly over
Honolulu,
Honolulu.
It's like so strange because the Hawaii,
you know,
a Wahoo,
I guess it is,
has a million people on it and it's not
that big man.
It's not that big at all.
Is that it right there?
You flew over and took the top photo.
I think Jamie's trying to still trying
to find it.
I think it would actually go to
scrolling or something.
Some reason his instagram pages and
letting me see past this last like 10
pictures I have to do.
There you go.
It's up on the screen now.
Unless you want to bring that up.
There you go.
Oh Wow.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
It's insane,
isn't it?
Like how do people think this is
sustainable?
Like let's just build a massive city on
a tiny little island with no food.
There's no food.
Everything's important.
They had a water crisis.
I think it was last year.
They had to import all.
If all the water.
This is on your instagram that people
could see that visit.
There's a shot on the instagram,
so that's.
That's chaotic.
It seems like one of the worst
engineered civilizations ever and so
there's no what we're looking at folks
with the people that are just listening
to this,
which is most of the people we're
looking at like a small island,
not very big because you can see the
entire thing and it's filled with
buildings.
There's no nothing but buildings.
It doesn't agree with any parks in
there.
I mean there's like a few field or
something like patches of green,
like very small,
but most of it is just stacked
buildings.
Yeah,
I mean it brings.
Whenever I look at this,
I just think of suburbia,
same thing,
like we all live in these little patches
of land that if we wanted to grow her
own food,
we couldn't support ourselves.
We couldn't support anything.
Well,
this is an argument for the asshole that
used to run Australia.
Right?
The guy had it,
right?
Yeah.
Don't let everybody come and ruin your
beautiful party.
You guys have a beautiful party.
You have a continental United States
with as many people as Los Angeles.
Yep.
But you have some spots where you can't
really live.
Right.
That's what I mean.
The whole interior is his death.
Livable people have massive out there.
Well,
China
owns massive ranchers out there.
China does.
That's a good one to bring up,
Jamie,
where there's a map of Australia and
Chinese ownership.
It's crazy.
We have sold.
We've sold a huge farms,
these massive,
massive farms in central Australia to
China over the last five years or so.
One of the farms growing cattle,
whatever it mainly,
mainly it's kind of a livestock.
And are these Chinese folks taking these
cattle and importing the beef in China
or like most of it will go straight to
China basically.
Wow.
So they just decided to buy some land
and grow some cows in a new spot.
Well we were already growing cows there,
but yeah,
they just bought them and then export
them to China.
But the just the sheer area is what's
crazy.
I'm looking for pictures of the thing.
But this is a block the size of an Ohio
sized ranch that's just the latest one
block the sale of a massive private
cattle ranch to foreign buyer saying it
was contrary to the national interest.
Mm.
Well I mean like it.
On one hand you'd say,
well hey that's,
that's Zena phobic and it's awful and
why would you do that?
But if you want to keep it the way it
is,
it's really no other way.
Right.
I just think,
you know,
the,
at the moment we as an Australian
people,
we don't get any real benefit from that.
We don't the profits go overseas or the
product produce goes overseas.
We're not really seeing any benefit for
it.
And that's,
you know,
if we,
if we didn't sell it,
if we leased it,
completely agree at least that stuff,
whatever,
you know,
but we should,
the Australian people should retain
ownership of that because I mean if ever
do find the map,
it's of course the colors and red to
make it scary.
And then it's a lot of Australia,
a billionaire buys $47,000,000
worth of Australian cattle ranches to
feed China's hunger for beef.
China's nuts.
What a crazy place.
It's uh,
it's interesting.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's,
I mean again,
the different styles of culture that we
find the different styles of the way
human beings exist and coexist on this
planet as one of the weirder aspects of
traveling that you see what's normal to
these people.
Oh,
it's different.
Every country you could everywhere and
they accept it.
It's like this is our normal.
What I like about China is that when it
makes the decision on something,
it's looking 40 years in the future
because it's by committee.
You know,
when we in Australia or the states,
you know,
we make a decision based on the election
cycle.
It's based in what can we get four years
time and that's where I think China will
actually leapfrog a lot of western
society because what they're doing now
is thinking about in 40 years time.
So they're building big infrastructure
before it's even required.
Where we in the Western world seem to
just have crumbling infrastructure.
Yeah.
We seem to be looking
like for years we looked like election
cycles.
Your elections,
crazy luck in your election.
Goes on for like two years in Australia,
that guy we're going to have an election
in 30 days time.
They'd go back and forth for 30 days.
We have an election,
30 days.
That's it.
Problem solved.
We had to stare at the people for
Awhile,
chip away at their armor,
try to find out what the fuck came for
like two years.
I mean that's just.
Yeah,
it's messed up.
It is messed up.
Well,
it's also nobody really that you would
want to be president wants to be
president,
you know?
Ideally you would want.
So why is that?
Well,
because they dig into your personal life
too much,
man.
They,
they start fucking with your family.
You start fucking with your finances and
fucking with.
They started interviewing people you
went to high school with and trying to
chip away at any one possible moral
issue you may or may not have had that
they can blow up and sticking your face
and you're down to these like you get
like egomaniacs,
like trump or massively religious people
like Ted Cruz and Ben Carson.
This is,
and I don't understand Marco Rubio,
he's,
he's an odd one.
And then you get Hillary Clinton who is
essentially a lifelong politician who
has been so deeply embedded into the
system that she isn't a massively low
trust rate.
Like the truck,
the wrist,
it's like 37 percent of people trust
her.
This is crazy.
I mean that's crazy.
Sixty three percent of like no fucking
way.
The vast majority,
you know,
the obvious majority at least are.
They're like,
I don't trust her at all.
And then they,
you know,
they have to.
So we have to see Joe Rogan for prison.
No fucking way.
I wouldn't want that job.
It's.
It's a terrible job.
Like it's a thing.
First of all,
what I honestly believe is that the idea
is massively archaic and I think the
idea of having this one alpha primate
that runs the tribe was fine if there's
100 people,
but the idea of 300 million people being
run by this one figurehead is nuts.
It doesn't work anymore.
It's stupid.
What we should have is the president
should be like the queen of England.
Some goofball gets out and fucking
bulletproof popemobile and drives around
a waves.
No one gives a shit,
but she doesn't really dictate policy
and I think the real president should be
the internet.
I really believe firmly that with
education and with access to information
that we're all enjoying right now,
that maybe not now because we're in this
sort of tumultuous turmoil filled
adolescent period,
but I think that as we get more and more
deeply embedded in the idea of
exchanging information,
I think we're going to be able to read
each other's minds.
We're going to be able to tap into
instantaneous information directly to
our mind and we're going to realize that
the only way this is all going to work
out is if we don't allow anyone to abuse
the environment for the sake of profit,
that we don't allow anyone to take life
for the sake of profit,
that we don't allow anyone to lie to us
about their motives for invading
countries or for for dictating certain
policy and especially for influencing
other countries in the fall for the
reason of profit.
We've got to.
We've got to stop that.
We got to figure out a way to stop that
and the only way to stop that is full
disclosure amongst our leader and his
parents.
Massive transparency and I think that's
going to happen in a natural way because
I think it's going to be unavoidable.
I think in the future,
like what you're seeing now.
I think one of the reasons why you've
seen this poor group of people running
for president is because the really rich
and influential people that maybe would
have run for president 20 or 30 years
ago.
I like fuck that job because it's just
too invasive and not only that,
once you become president,
you have to have secret service live
with you for the rest of your life.
I mean you're constantly on guard.
Everywhere you go.
People hate you.
I mean it's,
it's a crazy nut job.
It's a job.
It's almost like a,
you want it just because it's like this
thing to achieve and then.
But you,
if you look at it on paper,
like what,
what is.
It's not like you're independently
wealthy.
Once you get in,
you really make you make very good money
for the average person you make.
Like I think it's like 450 or $500,000
a year.
You know,
you certainly a good living,
but that's not like stuff with it.
It's not worth it then,
but they make money in the speeches.
That's really,
that's also the really weird thing you
find out like how much Bill Clinton
makes.
Giving speeches now.
It's almost like they bribe you,
like for,
for what your policies were in office.
It's sort of as only as sort of
unwritten rule like do the right thing
when you're in and then when you're out,
we'll have you come by.
If this company to this then
have you seen the democratic debates
between Bernie Sanders and Hillary
Clinton where he asks her for these
transcripts?
Oh,
good for you.
You probably live in better to what does
this 150,
$3,000,000
in bill and Hillary Clinton speaking.
Mrs Clinton was paid directly by Wall
Street suggesting a conflict of
interest.
Despite a recent distancing,
no matter how much Mrs Clinton hopes to
lure Bernie Sanders voters,
it must be hard at $220,000
to 200,
$5,000
a pop.
That's how much he gets paid for a
speech and he was like,
it must have been an amazing speech.
I'd like to see the transcript to this
beach.
She ain't and she not releasing those.
I've got a bit of trouble for saying
this about a year ago.
I honestly think the whole trump
candidacy is a conspiracy theory to make
hillary win because you have someone so
crazy on that side that people go,
all right,
okay.
Yeah,
we've had our fun,
but time to get serious and they go for
Hillary because it's the better option
of the two man where I don't fully agree
with that too.
The truth.
I don't think Hillary's a wonder.
I wonder,
but I've got to.
I've got to start for you,
Jay.
Okay.
On that trip to Easter island.
So we went from Tahiti to Easter island
for about two weeks ago and we had um,
had a gentleman on board who was kind of
my political hero.
Uh,
his name was Bob Brown,
Australian,
a senator,
leader of the Green Party.
And so when I was growing up,
you'd have your talking heads,
some topic coming on and you'd have
basically the Republican and the
Democrat,
we call them liberals and labor,
whatever.
And it would be stupid comment,
stupid comment.
And then you'd have this third one,
the Greens guy.
He would come on and then just say
something that actually made sense.
And so the whole time growing up,
he was a bit of a political hero of
mine,
nothing worship or anything like that.
But I went,
you know,
out of all the politicians,
this guy's got his head screwed on and
it's environmentally and progressive and
stuff like that.
Environmentally conscious.
So he was on board is one of our guests
lecturers kind of thing.
And he did lots of talks,
um,
fascinating,
fascinating guy.
And I remember I did my climate change
talk and so he came up to me afterwards
and I hadn't had a long conversation
with you.
And so I went to,
you know,
start going,
oh,
big fan,
Yada Yada.
And he turned around and when you add
them,
you,
you need to be in politics,
you need to be a senator for the Greens
in Australia.
And he pushed it big time especially,
you've got to do this,
you've got to do this.
We need,
you know,
younger people like you to do.
And I must admit,
I thought about it because I want to not
change the world,
but I want to do something to make this
earth a slightly better than what I
arrived.
Um,
and that's a way to do it for sure.
The thing that keeps me back from doing
it is I would have to put up with
politicians all day who would want to
put up with politicians,
order.
That's what I'm miserable bunch of
people and I don't know,
but I haven't watched much cspan of
Congress and stuff over here.
But our parliament,
they just sit there pitching each other
continuously,
if that's totally true.
It's like the English parliament and
ever seen where they'd just be using
each other basically and yelling,
calling each other names all the time
when they have a vote and they don't,
they,
they know the vote's not going to go
their way.
You didn't have to have like 60 percent
of the people there to make the vote
count.
They all run for the doors and try and
get out before they lock the doors so
that there's not enough people that
actually actually make it past.
They just act like little school
children kind of run.
They run.
Our prime minister is sprinting because
I go to.
The doors are going to be locked in two
minutes and he's Brinton out of his seat
to get out that door because we get to
that that door.
Then he doesn't vote and there's not
enough votes and then it doesn't go
through.
It's just like we paying these people to
represent us and they're just acting
like little children or goofy law.
Why would you want to.
Why would you want to surround yourself?
Imagine waking up everyday and
surrounding yourself with that.
I think we'd be way better off if
individual human beings across the
board,
like the giant mass of us,
if we all,
everyone adult had a say instead of an
elected government,
a representative government.
If we all had to say and we we'd have to
come up with one zero.
A real.
Exactly.
That's a great way of pointing it out.
I think the representative government
was great idea back in the day when it
was impossible to communicate with each
other.
We don't need it anymore.
We don't need it.
Two point zero.
There was a gentleman potty,
they.
They tried to do it and you know that
were quite successful but didn't get
elected into power so it couldn't do it,
but their idea was to use two point
zero.
We just make a website and you've got
whatever issue we're voting on.
Everyone can vote and and where I think
they went wrong because this is
something I've thought about quite
considerably is where they went wrong is
they're trying to change the whole
system.
So the gun,
we're going to come in,
we're gonna change the whole system and
people freak out.
Then of course,
so I feel it.
Hang on.
Is there a way to achieve the same goal
but through the nonprofit angle instead
of trying to change the whole thing,
and so it's something I started on,
I started working on and it's been put
to the sidelines because I travel the
world and I'm busy,
but earth vote.network
where you had a place where you could go
and vote like a petition,
but it's that one question that you
answer stays on forever and so then
because in Australia all the time you
pick up a Murdoch newspaper and it'll
say 94 percent of Australians think this
and then you read down the bottom out of
a survey of a 500 people ringing
landlines in one suburb in Sydney.
I'm like,
that's not a representation of what's
going on.
Imagine if I could turn around and go,
here's half a million people and he is
the percentage of what they think.
Then you're getting a more accurate
representation of what's going on.
I think there's room for a website like
that and obviously I've kind of given up
on doing it myself,
hence why I'm mentioning it right now.
Hopefully someone else takes it up,
but there's huge potential in taking
clicktivism,
which we currently see on facebook and
everything.
Everyone's happy to click on a link and
spread the good word about some
environmental concern,
but actually do something they're not so
willing to do.
If you collate all that clicktivism into
one spot and then you have data coming
out of it,
it actually becomes useful with actually
can be used where you can go to a
politician,
say,
hey,
80 percent of your electric think this
so your represent them.
Go do it and you've got some way.
And then the other aspect to it is to
then actually do a kind of vote,
not voting.
Um,
keep a system of the politicians.
So say 80 percent of Australia thinks
this things and then the politician,
the votes for a bill that's against
that.
Then you give them a minus one point,
they vote for it,
you get an a plus one point,
you know.
And so eventually you would work out
basically which politicians are
accurately representing their
constituents and which ones are not.
And that's what we don't have.
How do you know that this guy that
you're voting for has been representing
the constituents?
You don't really know.
You've got to go back and look through
10 years of newspaper articles and try
and deduce it.
Imagine if you could formulate that into
a website,
you.
It'd be a pretty powerful thing.
It'd be a very powerful thing.
I think that's the future.
I think the future,
as we were saying,
as we get more access to,
you know,
the way people are influenced,
when we understand where the money's
actually coming from,
which is way more today than it's ever
been in the past 30,
40 years ago.
It was really difficult to out what was
motivating certain presidents or people
that were candidates and you only got to
see what they were projecting in front
of the television what they were.
That's why debates are important.
You get to see the way they spoke and
debates.
Try to decipher and peel through it,
but no,
we never had the kind of transparency
that we have today and this is
you want to know what's really going on
with a politician.
Get them on the Joe Rogan podcast,
get politician for three hours.
They accomplish it for that long.
That would be at some point you would
get under them and you would find out
what's actually going to do.
A lot of research though that,
so I couldn't just have mom like you and
just go,
let's talk man.
I would have to go deep,
but yeah,
you get someone to talk for long periods
of time uncensored like that.
Without commercial breaks,
without moderators.
Then you're going to get to see him.
These debates that they have are so
ridiculous.
One person says something ridiculous to
see Bernie Sanders raising his hand when
he disagrees,
waiting to have his turn and then she's
talking over and then he talks over and
you're running out of time,
but let me finish my point.
And he goes,
oh,
it's like the,
the,
the method of distributing information
is archaic.
It's not necessary anymore.
You know,
they should,
they should have some sort of a free
form,
free form conversation.
It's available online where people can
watch it and you know,
you have someone who was entertaining
that understands politics,
run them through it and just give some
sort of a,
a real detailed view to the American
people of who these people are and what
they're about,
but I think they're the people that are
today.
Even Bernie Sanders who's a really
revolutionary and a lot of ways and very
progressive in a lot of ways.
There's still a politician,
you know,
he's still wearing a tie and a suit and
all that nonsense and he's still a part
of this weird system and he always has
been,
even though he's a rebel in a lot of
ways,
but I think they're going to be like
those people that are wearing powdered
wigs and those ancient pictures.
It's like it's so old.
It's so crazy.
Like this method of doing it,
like you have to do it this way.
Lawyers in Australia as to where those
weeks do they really?
Yeah.
It's crazy what?
Yep.
When you do it's magic.
So if you go to court,
you have to wear a wig.
The lawyer in certain certain quotes.
So if you got in trouble for something
that the defendant doesn't have to know,
but I'm saying your lawyer,
like what the fuck am I looking at,
Jamie?
That's a Barista.
Okay.
So for you guys got to get on the
fucking ball.
You guys are crazy.
So sorry to interject.
But I did.
So if you get in trouble,
if you did something,
if you got accused of something and you
hired a lawyer,
your lawyer would have to wear a wacky
wig like that.
Yes.
Wow.
Sit in certain courts.
What courts?
Oh,
now you're stretching my memory on it.
A lot of them think it's,
it's not a magistrate,
a barrister.
Um,
yeah,
something like that.
Good Lord.
Definitely New South Wales and some of
them.
Yeah.
I actually,
I went to court for the first time
last year.
First time for what?
Uh,
I got a charged with being a terrorist.
You did for something environmental?
I would imagine not.
What'd you do?
I uh,
I went through airport security with a
pocket knife by accident.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
We in Australia.
We're a bit of a nanny state at the
moment.
Uh,
we've brought in a lot of laws that just
ridiculous and so it used to be you go
through airport security with your Swiss
army knife,
they take it off you and they go right
in a way you go,
you know,
that's it.
They changed the law two weeks before I
went through and it was just,
it was just a random mistake.
I had a pocket knife in with the camera
gear.
I had to rearrange my bank because I was
overweight.
Um,
and I put it in my carry on by mistake.
I didn't realize that pocket knife is,
it's simple mistake.
We do it all the time and people do it
all the time.
And uh,
yeah,
so they got it and I was like,
oh crap,
because it's a good knife.
I was like,
oh,
well,
whatever.
I'm late for my flight.
And then I went to walk away and they
went,
oh,
hang on here when the Australian Federal
Police need to speak to you.
I'm like,
oh my God.
So the police came over and they were,
they were trying to give me off on a
course and they were ringing their
superior and trying to get me caught
because I could see clear as day that is
just stupid mistake.
And the supplier said,
no,
that's the laws change,
they have to go to court now.
And so I was charged with possession of
a deadly weapon basically with intent to
hijack and aircraft and it cost me
thousands of dollars because it wasn't
the airport I got done.
It was about 2000 kilometers away from
where I live.
So I had to travel back there and then I
had to get a lawyer,
which was just hilarious.
I pay a thousand dollars.
He didn't even show up.
He sent someone else,
gave me a call half an hour beforehand.
Um,
yeah,
everything was just like.
And so I was,
I knew more about the law than he did.
But anyway.
And so then the substitute lawyer?
Yeah.
Oh God.
I knew more about the actual
legislation.
I was getting challenged and basically I
got the legislation has no difference
between a bazooka and a in a pocket
knife that the same thing.
Ak Forty seven and it's the same thing
in the.
You kill somebody with it.
If.
So it's the same thing.
It's the same thing.
If I try to get through airport security
with a bazooka,
I'd be under the same legislation and
under the same thing.
And so I got off lightly instead of get
used in jail.
Um,
because obviously first offense,
no,
no prior record or that sort of stuff.
I got a,
there's a fancy word for it.
I want to say indentured servitude,
but that's not it.
It's like a good behavior bond.
So I got four for the next year.
As long as you don't break any more
laws,
then that conviction will disappear
basically.
Wow.
But yeah,
I went to court,
charged with being a terrorist for
bloody pocket knife and that's when I
must have been after that.
I was trying to think.
I didn't really want to live in
Australia anymore because it's just
gotten a bit too crazy.
Do you think that's the same sort of a
momentum that's behind,
like getting rid of the immigrants and
shipping them off to new places and
putting people in jail for reporting on
it?
Least have some thing,
Patriot Act where they bring in a law
that does all this sort of stuff and
they don't debate.
It just goes instantly through and no
one even reads the law of what's going
through and we had this whole.
It was so staged if so easily you could
see was staged where they had.
We've arrested 20 terrorists in Sydney
now.
They actually had to let them all go
because they didn't have anything on
anyone but they filmed it and it was on
national news of them writing all these
places and then immediately brought in a
week later,
new laws and that no one debated.
No one even written brought him in and
one of those laws were,
yeah,
you take a pocket knife through airport
security.
You have to go to court to defend
yourself.
That's such a stupid.
With law,
I mean the United States laws which are
pretty strict or nothing like that.
I went through security accidentally
with a pocketknife they just took,
it
was a,
everyone does this,
but I,
I just spend 3000,
$4,000,
million money and try and work this out
that way and now to this day,
whenever I travel my bags,
if I have a short short transit,
my bags went make it because they get
searched every single a protocol on the
list.
I just spent three weeks in Antarctica
with no luggage.
It never,
it never arrived.
Oh Christ.
Because it went through extra security
in and then didn't arrive for a couple
of days and I was already down in
Antarctica
just because of a pocket knife just
because of a pocket knife.
Yeah,
in America.
I went through it in Denver.
I had a backpack and the backpack in one
of the small pockets that are very small
knife in it and they sent me through
secondary screening was I think you got
a pocket knife in your backpack or
sorry,
the guy took it and that was it.
Yeah,
take it easy.
Okay,
bye.
Done.
That's what it's always been locked,
but they changed the law.
That's so crazy.
That doesn't make any sense at all.
It's just,
it's a waste of my money.
It's a waste of the court's money.
What do you think they're doing it to
try to make more money by making more
court cases?
Well,
I had to pay the court costs.
I mean obviously,
but I,
I just think it's Laura upon laws in
Australia,
we are shocking at laws upon laws and
laws.
No one speeds in Australia.
I drove down from San Francisco
yesterday and it was ludicrous how fast
people would drive the speed limit
because the speed that they were driving
like 40 k's over the speed limit is
something that in Australia is you lose
your license instantly.
You don't have a license for the next
year,
so really?
Yeah.
So no one's speeds like that for a year.
Oh God.
So yeah.
But that's because we just have so many
laws.
We just have so many different laws in
that respect.
That's disturbing.
But that's not what I wanted to talk to
you about.
Men bumming me out about Australia.
I was thinking about moving to
Australia.
I'm like,
maybe that's the spot.
I've heard that a lot from the American
since trump is doing his thing.
No,
it's not because of that.
I just think I just like it.
I mean I wouldn't really move there,
but like if the shit hit the fan,
someone blew up Manhattan or something
like that.
I'm like,
Ooh,
time of jolt or bolt,
whatever,
whatever it is.
That's an interesting one.
Where I was for nine slash 11.
Where were you?
I was in up in the very northern reaches
of Australia in the middle of nowhere.
I'm so far away that you couldn't get
any signal for anything,
but one of the people on board had a
shortwave radio,
like a ham radio and so I learned of
nine slash 11 via radio and it was like
war of the worlds man.
It sounded like the whole world was
going to shine and.
But we were on a boat in the middle of
nowhere and we did kind of just all
looked at each other and go,
well we got two or three months supply
of food here.
We can stretch that out with fishing and
we're in the middle of nowhere.
We can go sit up that creek over there
and yeah,
we were kind of pretty bugged out.
It wasn't until about two months later
they actually got back and saw the
images of what happened.
But it sounds like war of the worlds
when you listened to that sort of event
over a radio,
it was scary.
That's a weird way to get information
to.
So,
so like retro,
you know,
to get information about some sort of a
gigantic catastrophe or calamity
horrendous event.
Like nine slash 11 to get an over radio,
like just,
it sounded like world war three.
That's what it sounded like from the
radio at least.
Yeah.
It's like,
well it looked like world war three on
tv that day too though,
in all fairness.
I remember watching on TV and went with
a bunch of my friends because there was
no flights.
I had some gigs planned.
I couldn't go.
So actually supposed to be in Manhattan
that week.
Lucky.
Yeah.
Um,
I was supposed to fly to Manhattan the
week after September 11 that all flights
were canceled and I remember hanging out
with some friends in La and everyone was
bugging out like why is going to happen?
And then we were aware because of the
news that there was no flights and it
was a beautiful,
clear skies.
It was strange,
strange.
Hey,
look up like there's no,
no airplanes.
Yeah,
just nothing.
You don't hear him.
You look up,
you don't see any.
I think it was some of the clear skies
ever recorded over the USA.
Everything.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
the temperature lowered changed the
temperature of the earth or maybe
raised,
I forget one of the water vapor.
It would've lowered.
Yeah,
it would've got a little bit cool.
Is that what it is?
Because things happened and we'll either
raised or lowered depending upon the.
There was also the water vapor could
protect the atmosphere and a lot because
it's like cloud cover,
you know,
when you get contrary contracts on which
one it was,
but it was like a noticeable amount that
it changed a CEO to an airplane's
pumping out.
It's nothing too serious.
This is one of the most efficient forms
of transport you can have put person,
but where it's injecting that CEO too
and that water vapor up in that,
you know,
in the high atmosphere it's,
it's doing some damage.
It is not as much as I think we give it
credit for.
Well the other thing is people that live
near airports suffer some sick.
What does that.
Jamie would just put up.
It got hotter actually.
Yeah.
Did two degrees hotter.
That's what I was thinking because I
think is the lack of.
Because those trails that are created,
the artificial clouds that are by jet
engines naturally stirring up the
humidity.
Maybe they're reflecting back solar
radiation.
Well that's where all the chem trail
craziness comes from.
The geoengineering people,
they believe that that is actually done
on purpose and then what we're doing is
we're,
we're making artificial clouds try to
control the environment.
Well,
it's not true.
I mean we know why those things are
made.
They're made.
It's a natural formation that happens
when you have a jet engine passes
through condensation.
It creates contract is not chem trails.
I always try and point that one out.
It's a,
there's a guy named Mick West who runs
this website called Metta bunk and just
sort of debunks a lot of like really
commonly held ideas that conspiracy
theories tend to grab onto,
but he calls it the training wheels of
conspiracy theories because it's like in
the sky above your head.
Like what is that?
And they're like,
we've got to get to the bottom of this,
you know,
and that's sort of where instead of like
researching what actually happens with
jet engines and condensation and it on,
people say,
well,
how come one day there'll be no
cantrell's and another dude will be a
lot.
Well,
how come one day it rains and the other
day it doesn't really fit you really
well.
It's condensation and it's how the
amount of moisture in the atmosphere.
It's whatever.
This is a different subject.
Um,
I wanted to talk to you about some other
shit that you had on your,
um,
you had a neurological decompression
illness from you.
You're trying to give a happy here,
but this is actually getting sad.
Well this is scary.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a story.
I was hoping you're going to do another
one.
Oh really?
And it's certainly we can do that.
We don't have to.
I want to tell you it's just,
it's a depressing,
depressing what happened.
So I'm scuba diving,
scuba diving since I was 12 years old,
a $13,000.
I'm asking a lot of time underwater.
Whoa.
And uh,
so one light sites inevitable.
I don't know.
But uh,
so I was diving nothing too serious,
you know,
a shallow dive.
It was a bit of a car and I was turning
into a bit of a current,
maybe slightly dehydrated,
who knows?
Um,
but yeah,
I got messed up now.
I've been diving for nine days prior to
that full dives a day,
so I'd had some residual nitrogen.
I've got bubbles in my blood basically,
and then doing this one,
I guess a little bit of exertion
underwater and stuff like that.
Yeah,
I got messed up.
So when I came out of the water you have
a bad headache and stuff like that.
And then um,
eventually I was looking down at my
hands and my hands had gone into Phis
and I couldn't open my hands anymore.
And that to me was the big thing
straight away I was like,
Whoa,
I've never had that before where I
didn't have control of my buddy,
you know.
And so my hands were world class,
so I ran upstairs to my bunk,
told the first night,
you know,
get the oxygen and stuff like that.
I've got something's going wrong here.
And then when I laid down in my bunk,
I just severe pain going over the whole
entire body.
Arms enhance both totally paralyzed.
Couldn't move them enormous,
enormous amount of pain.
A box jellyfish pain or no,
no,
no.
Nothing near that.
I think more discussion
paying because you just don't know
what's going on,
you know,
you just don't know.
Your whole body is just suddenly doing
stuff that it's never done before.
Um,
and so when an oxygen and ended up
passing out actually after a few,
maybe half an hour.
So I ended up passing out and then woke
up and I was just really dopey and
doughy and stuff.
And long story short,
um,
for various reasons I didn't actually
get treatment for about six days.
It was very remote area in this.
There's all this stuff there and uh,
and then I spent nine days in a chamber
decompression chamber basically to try
and try and repair what had gone wrong
because I had nerve damage in the hands
and feet,
spine and brain.
So I had quite a significant brand
damage.
Um,
the spine damage,
the spine causes a lot of fatigue and
things like that.
And then the hands and feet just pain
basically.
Um,
yeah,
that happened in 2012.
I got messed up,
messed up.
So brain damage,
like what kind of brain damage?
A literally brain damage.
So what's going on in my body is lots of
little tiny bubbles basically are all
nerves,
bloodstream everywhere,
and they cause inflammation and they,
they kill stuff.
I had a lot of muscle atrophy,
you know,
I had a lot of muscles just die on me
cause they,
their blood supply had been blocked by
these little bubbles going around.
Do you see like a difference in your
body to turn black and blue or does it
shrink?
Like what you,
you lose your,
all your muscle mass,
just shrivels you lose your muscle mass.
It changed the appearance of the skin.
Like does it seem like yellowing where
it's rotting underneath or anything?
Nothing like that.
Um,
I had to learn how to walk again.
I could barely walk and I had to learn.
Vocabulary was a hard one.
I said we're really good vocabulary now.
Not so much anymore.
I,
I killed a lot of brain cells.
Brain cells,
you feel stupid.
Or I had,
I tested my Iq beforehand and I was
about 150,
160 marketing and now I'm about 120.
So you're still a fucking genius.
I wouldn't go that far,
but some Iq points.
That's.
Well,
you used to be a genius for sure.
I'm a photographic memory.
I won 51.
Sixty is definitely a genius.
I thought too much.
Basically it's better for you to feel a
little stupid.
Well,
I enjoy bad movies now.
There you go.
Yeah,
because Adam Sandler movies,
so like reese witherspoon movie,
any movie this predictable where before
I'd be like,
I know it was legally blonde to watch
that over and over again.
Any of these movies and that's it.
But I appreciate bad movies.
There's always a.
there's always a positive side to
everything.
So do you really?
It's so it actually made you
significantly less intelligent and you
can consume pop culture now.
Yeah.
Basically.
Do you enjoy reality shows now that
Beverly Hills housewife?
My TV at home as an isn't actually
connected to an area little.
Oh,
you're one of those guys.
I don't like advertising.
I think advertising is evil.
So you use like Netflix or something
like that?
Well that's smart.
That's the future anyway,
right?
You're ahead of the ball.
Anything goods on itunes already,
you know,
most of the good shows in a walking dead
or game of thrones or anything like
that.
You could always find them,
well I want to choose my own schedule as
well.
I don't want to be,
oh,
Wednesday night and I have to stay in
because I want to watch that one show.
Like my kids don't know what commercials
are really.
They don't understand it and most of the
time we watch shows with them.
We watched on Dvr and you could fast
forward through commercials,
but occasionally we'll watch like one of
their favorite shows and it'll come on
and they'll watch it while it's on and
then the show will be on and then it'll
go to commercial and they reach for the
remote and it's like,
don't.
It's not letting them fast forward and
like what is going on here?
Like why do we have to watch this?
I'm like,
well that's a commercial.
That's it.
That's how it normally is.
Welcome to what we had to deal with,
but the look on their little faces when
you see a little look on like a five or
six year old's face,
we were like,
what the fuck you I have to.
I have to watch this stupid thing.
And they're watching these commercials
like,
like puzzled,
like who?
Like even a child realizes this is a
dumb way to advertise.
Advertise things.
Yeah.
It's,
it's actually,
I think it makes you not want to
purchase those things.
They've interrupted your program,
but that's because you're intelligent.
I would say it does work for a vast
majority of people who don't,
you know,
it's just subliminal than not even
thinking about it,
but it just goes in,
Hey,
I want to cook.
Don't you think it works less and less
though.
Possibly as we get disassociated with
it,
with Netflix and stuff like that as we
move away from it.
But I think,
I think advertising is evil.
Haven't seen the south park related
sandbox.
I go onto it quite well,
but advertising,
yeah,
I see why it's there,
but yeah,
it really bugs me and it bugs me
probably also because in Australia we
have such terrible ads.
We had Chris Bell and Mark Bell from the
documentary,
bigger,
stronger,
faster and the new one,
prescription thugs where they go over
the effect of the prescription drug
industry and what massive influence it
has on people and the amount of people
that are hooked on pain pills and
whatnot.
It was bands in Australia by the way.
They should be and they were talking in
the documentary about during the Reagan
administration when they became legal
and they started advertising for all
these drugs and how how much different
the landscape changed when all of a
sudden there was an ad then showed you
all these things that may be you have an
issue and maybe you should talk to your
doctor about this stuff,
and then you know the sales go through
the roof.
They get addicted to that money that
comes from no sales.
It's a really disturbing aspect of our
society that you can advertise for drugs
like prescription.
How many pharmaceuticals,
how many different drugs and American an
average American is on at any one point?
When I was in the dive industry as a
supervisor,
I would get lists of everyone on board
and their medical conditions and what
drugs that are currently taking and
Australian.
It's just like,
oh,
Yep,
yep.
Nothing,
nothing bump and American that have five
or six things listed there,
and then I would have to actually go do
the research on each drug and see if
they conflicted with diving and stuff
like that.
It was a lot of work and you kind of
like,
oh,
this is an upper and this is a downer
and this is a kind of level or well,
people of antidepressants and they have
an extra abilify that they add to an
antidepressant.
If that antidepressant isn't doing the
job,
but it could cause society a society to
collapse and your asshole explodes and
you bleed out and some side effects may
have suicidal thoughts.
It's apparently like there's a lot
attached to it,
like the fine print at the end when they
scroll through it and may cause Mama,
it's like this huge list of
possibilities that could go horribly
wrong,
but some people they just always think
that a pill is the answer and I think
that's also part of the programming
that's sort of been in diamond.
I'm in a really tough spot this point in
the last few years basically because
I've always believed,
don't take a pill for the rest of you,
like take.
You've got a headache,
you take a headache pill route,
but you don't take a pill every single
day of your life.
There's no point for that.
Or you have something like diabetes or
something right to shop.
There's always some exceptions there,
but lo and behold,
most people can actually with diabetes
even changed their diet and sort of go
that way.
There are ways to do without taking a
pill every day,
but now I'm under this thing where since
that accident with decompression
sickness,
I have pain constantly in pain
constantly.
What you're hiding it very well.
Well,
what do you do with your life?
You just cry.
Go over there and cry.
I'll hide in the corner.
But what are you gonna do?
Like what kind of pain is it like you're
in right now?
Hands and feet.
Basically the hands and feet are
throbbing or aching.
Stabbing pain feels like someone's got a
need right now and have a stabbing pain
in your hands and feet and you just
become accustomed to.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's all the nerve damage as you looked
into hypobaric hyperbaric chambers or
nine days straight after it happened to
barrick chambers.
So I did nine days in hyperbaric
chambers.
Looked into continue therapy with that.
Um,
it's not something that'll.
Let me tell you.
I would have to go pay for it myself.
Yes.
I'd have to pay thousands of dollars to
go get oxygen therapy for like,
football is football.
Let's go do it.
So they heal quicker.
If you actually talked to a doctor that
would say it probably wouldn't do much
because you do it after the event and
that.
But now we're talking four years later
and they're like,
eh,
probably wouldn't do much.
But there's not a lot of.
The problem with decompression sickness
is there's not a lot of evidence.
There's not a lot of research.
There is a holy per research,
but it's classified by the US marines,
US Navy,
most of the evidence and most of the
stuff out there,
it's very,
there's not a lot of data.
And so I remember going to these doctors
and they're like,
we don't really know.
How do you go?
There's no set plan.
Oh,
you get decompression sickness.
Where do we go from here to,
to fix it?
There isn't that kind of,
oh,
we'll try this,
we'll try this drug,
we'll try this drug and we'll just keep
trying different drugs and see what
happens basically.
Whoa.
I've tried a lot of drugs in the last 40
years.
What has offered you the most relief?
Um,
I'll get in trouble for saying it.
But a acupuncture was actually with it.
You get in trouble for saying that.
The anti acupuncture lobby,
basically I had to find some guy who,
who kind of did it.
He was a doctor and then he did
acupuncture as we call it,
bulk billing is part of the government
sort of thing so I could get it.
Um,
so I did that and that reduced my pain
by about half a straight afterwards.
Yeah,
huge thing.
The other drugs I tried.
Oh God,
um,
I mean the names we'll kind of mix over
here.
So think the first thing they did is
they check you on any presence,
Cymbalta,
that sort of stuff.
Um,
because they're like,
well,
he's just having trouble adjusting to
the fact that he's in pain all the time,
so let's give me an antidepressant.
So he's happy,
which it does take the edge off,
but it's a kind of half against it.
But B,
it just,
you just had to keep upping the dose,
you know,
you started from 10 milligrams and then
in a month's time it wouldn't do
anything anymore.
You Go to 20 and you just keep upping
the dose and so you just become
accustomed to the dosage because it's
not taking the pain away.
It's just taking the edge off,
you know,
making it,
not think about it.
So much
one of the reasons why a friend of mine
got off of them,
he said,
you,
he realized like you're going to get
adapted to whatever dose they give you
and then they're going to come up with
some.
Well,
this isn't working anymore because your
body's accustomed to it.
You built up a tolerance.
So we're gonna try a new SSRI on you.
Yeah,
yeah.
I eventually got off the Cymbalta
because it was just,
I was getting to basically the
depressive dosage.
I was getting up to 60 milligrams or
something and so I was like,
well,
I don't want to keep going with this.
And quite frankly it's not doing much.
So I got off that and they put me on one
court Lyrica,
which has an epileptic drug.
Jesus,
um,
I've tried a lot of drugs and air that
just mess with me,
mess with my head.
I had to quit it because I was going to
lose my job because I just didn't turn
up to work anymore.
I would sleep through my alarms and wake
up four or five hours later and dislike
it just missed with me and I was captain
of the ship at the time.
So I'm like,
I can't be driving this ship.
I can't be in charge of all these people
and being messed up on some epileptic
drugs.
So I stopped doing that one.
Then what I try after that,
uh,
in depth,
which is a,
it's a,
any depressant from the sixties I
believe it's not used at all anymore,
but there's no evidence.
There's like,
oh,
we have like 10 drugs here that sends
some experiments experimenting on you.
And so I've been on that one for a
while.
The same thing I just kept getting,
well the first time I took it I actually
slept for about 20 hours straight.
It just messed me up.
So I've been kind of very low doses of
it and once again it just stopped.
Not really doing much for the pain.
And then I said,
I've just spent three weeks in the
Antarctic with no bags,
which means no medication either.
So actually spent three weeks without
it.
And I noticed straight away I had more
energy during the day.
It actually caused me to be fatigued for
the morning,
um,
and I don't have that anymore.
And the level of pain tolerance that it
was giving me was just insignificant.
So now I'm just back to popping a pill
when it gets too much at night.
Uh,
at the moment,
coating pan,
we call it Panadeine Forte,
which is a paracetamal and a small dose
according to just try to get some sleep.
Yeah,
just to the insomnia.
You get insomnia from all the pain.
So that's what I try and do.
Um,
yeah,
they,
the next one they wanted me to try with
methadone.
I know that one yet.
Jesus Christ,
that's what they do to get people off of
heroin.
That's just a Guinea pig.
They just keep experimenting with me.
Fuck man.
That's,
that seems so crazy.
Well,
hopefully people will listen to this,
that have some information though.
I'm open to ideas.
I hope they do reach out to you.
Um,
you had pirates in here as a subject to
bring up.
Did you have any experience with pirate?
I'm know Tom Hanks movie.
No,
no,
I just used to do a talk on it.
We did a through,
you know,
sort of not past Somalia but Tanzania,
Maldives,
Seychelles around that whole area.
So a lot of people want to talk about
policy.
So I have a little presentation that I
kind of did on piracy in there,
but what I quite liked to show people is
actually I liked bringing new technology
into the equation.
So there's a website called live piracy
map,
and you can actually see a map of,
of the world and all the current pirate
attacks around the world.
It's pretty cool.
Was that something to be concerned with
when you're driving around that big
hundred million dollar beautiful boat?
No,
not at all.
No.
Do you guys have security with you?
No,
not at all.
We fucked up saying that.
She'd say,
yeah,
armed to the teeth superhero.
If I told you I'd have to kill.
You know what?
Pirates attack a cargo ship.
Something with very little crew,
10 cruise,
something like that.
They attack something that's a big prize
with very little people protecting it.
They don't.
Occasionally they'll go for yachts a
little time and yachts that cruise
ships,
I think the last sort of cruise ship or
big ship that they tried to attack as
they came up alongside it,
all guests on board grabbed all the
outdoor furniture or the sun lounges and
stuff like that and threw it at the
people coming up in the little boats and
killed some of them.
Um,
with furniture.
The furniture there with the pirates
were killed by falling furniture from
the roof.
Um,
so they just don't do it.
There's how you jump on board a ship
like a that I'm on and you have 100
guests and you have 80 credits,
180 people.
You're going to try and manage,
um,
you know,
kind of get away with it.
Like there's the pirate map or the.
Yeah.
So that's the,
the piracy map.
So you can click on each one of those
little,
um,
little tags and it will tell you a
little story.
This is all done by the insurance
agencies obviously,
but it's just fascinating to see what's
going on and what I was trying to always
show to people is that people always go
Somali pirates.
There isn't actually much piracy there
anymore.
Very,
very little.
Most of it's actually the Straits of
Malacca Singapore around.
They're real and most of the piracy is
we're the largest shipping channels are
basically.
Well,
the Somalian story we've talked about on
the podcast many times,
unfortunately I don't want to reiterate
it,
but those people were forced into it
because of people dumping toxic waste
are fishermen were dumping toxic waste
off their shores and they kidnap them to
try to stop this dumping and then they
got a massive ransom and realize like,
whoa,
hey,
fuck fishing.
Just start kidnapping people.
No,
no one turns into a pirate or a
terrorist.
It's a.
it's a function of where they've grown
up and the experiences they've had that
have pushed them to that limit.
You know,
you've pushed them
to the edge.
There's always a reason for it.
Well,
the battle for resources and the
inequality of the resources and what you
can get in the world,
it just leads people to desperation and
that's what,
you know,
going back to the alien thing,
that's what we would hope one day we
would get past when you get past this.
I mean we,
we'd understand that like if we just
looked at the world,
I mean if somehow or another we realized
that there's some sort of is a way to be
completely altruistic,
right?
There's a way to be completely even and
fair and we would look at the globe and
say,
well look,
there's plenty of resources.
We have boats and ships and let's just
evenly distributed all this stuff and
figure out a way we could all live in
harmony and everybody contribute,
but
it's.
It's difficult with the way things are
right now.
It's very difficult to move into that
place.
We'd have to have some sort of a massive
transcendence.
I'd like to go more into the whole
climate change thing normally before I
bring this up,
but at the same time I started off very
optimistic.
I started doing climate change talks,
2007.
I was very,
very optimistic that we can do this,
we can do this,
we can do this now.
Fast forward almost 10 years later and
I'm apocalyptic mystic.
Yeah,
it's I,
I think really if we want to change
what's going on now,
like any problem with when adults come
to you with a problem,
have you tried turning it on and off?
I really think we kind of.
We get to the point now where we really
got to turn it all off and then start it
back up again in a carbon neutral kind
of way.
That's what we're getting to right now
because what we're seeing now,
this is something that eludes most
people.
The effects we're seeing now,
which is two degrees Celsius above
degrees Celsius about industrial reits.
The attic at the moment is 12 to 16
degrees Celsius above the average
preindustrial time.
All this sort of stuff going on.
It's,
it's,
there's a 40 year lag between what we
pump out in pollution and CEO to,
to what the actual temperature rises.
So what we're seeing now is from the mid
seventies,
we haven't even got up to the eighties
yet.
That's bananas.
Yeah.
You imagine what the next 10 years.
The eighties.
What?
What the what we did to the world during
the eighties.
When you're in Antarctica,
do you look for places to move?
Just say,
Ooh,
built a house here.
Thirty years.
It'd be the shit.
It's.
It's not too far off.
No,
it's actually really quite well in the
Antarctic peninsula.
It's a bit of a hot spot as well.
It's warm.
I've got a picture,
I've got a picture there of me in t
shirts and shorts.
So you're talking this 30 degrees
Celsius warmer there,
which is what does that in America?
In America Fair.
Fair enough.
Okay.
So we've talked about the Arctic.
The Arctic at the moment is in some
areas about 12 degrees Celsius above the
preindustrial levels.
So God,
I never go to Fahrenheit,
but I would say yeah,
24,
almost 30,
33 is very annoying that we have
different ways of telling the
temperature that is so goofy and
kilograms to like when we go to England
is the most ridiculous.
They have stone when we do weigh ins for
the UFC in England with 13 stone,
like what are you even talking about?
Why you've met stones,
like what?
Thirteen pounds or something crazy like
that.
Some random ancient fucking king shit.
Somebody had a rock and they wanted
everybody to be measured by that route
to put this out there.
Metric system is a wonderful thing.
So way to go.
We should have adopted it should we
tried.
When I was in high school before high
school,
I believe,
I believe junior high school,
there were.
There was an attempt to indoctrinate the
American people on soccer and the metric
system wholesale.
We're like,
no,
we dug our heels in.
No soccer.
I cannot understand but a metric system.
I just.
I wonder like when you're in school,
like trying to learn maths and science,
not using the metric system.
That must be hard work,
man.
You remember all that sort of stuff.
It's kind of silly because you can do,
you can see the metric system is better.
It's a better system.
It's a system of 10.
You know when you get into inches and
yards and systems of 12,
12 inches and like,
okay,
how many yards is a.
What was a meter to a yard is how much
difference.
Okay.
Ninety meters is almost the same,
but there's,
there's variables and then the kilos
thing,
the kilograms and measuring that and
Fahrenheit and Celsius.
It's,
it's dumb.
Like one system would be great.
They could have done it.
They could have stuck with it in the
sixties and the seventies.
We could have been all right.
Right now man,
don't the rest of the world.
We're wherever with metric system.
Come join us.
We're not England though.
They had the stones,
but they have miles.
Yeah,
Yup.
You sure?
I'm pretty sure.
I don't think these kilometers.
See if England uses miles.
I think these miles,
I think they use inches,
feet miles.
Pretty sure if they use inches and feet
and he was kilometers,
they're retarded.
No wacky.
I fill it.
It was you guys and a USA in Bhutan were
the only people in the be looking like
that.
Let's see.
Uh,
they longed.
What does it say in the UK?
Miles are used almost exclusively on
road signs I just used in
road sense.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Well,
I'm thinking in there,
not just road science.
I think they also use it on their
spirometers like,
you know,
35 miles an hour because you.
Have you ever spent Amr?
I mean,
they're not going to use it just on the
road.
Signs of their fucking car doesn't say
what it is.
I'm sure it's in their automobiles to
tweed.
Having a mixed like that isn't.
It is weird.
It wasn't too aware of that.
Will England's not a mix.
They use that.
We are their system.
I mean the reason why we use inches and
feet,
feet and all that jazz was because of
them.
Miles.
That's,
that's England.
What we did too.
Of course in Australia we got smart.
You guys wised up.
Another reason why Australia is awesome,
as I said,
we,
we have our moments,
we do.
We were the second nation,
let women vote.
We got a lot of good things behind us
that being very progressive and kind of
ahead of the loop on a few things,
but who's the first us,
New Zealand,
New Zealand.
The first people that people.
Women vote.
Yeah.
Goddamn beautiful.
It's a beautiful kind of.
A buddy of mine was over there right
now.
Send me some pictures.
I was like,
yeah,
it's a pretty place.
I try and get there wherever I can.
What is your favorite place to visit or
do you have a favorite place you've
explored?
I mean,
you've literally been.
Because every,
every expedition.
I don't give me a favor.
Tell me about something awesome.
Every expedition I do has something
amazing that we do,
you know?
And so every single one,
there's one place that I really,
really like.
Um,
so there's lots and yeah,
it's hot.
But if you were to specify specific
expedition,
I can tell you the highlights of it.
So probably one of my favorite place in
the world at the moment is south
Georgia,
which is a,
you know,
the Falkland Islands,
it's just over a little bit further into
the,
into the ocean there east.
And so you've got this little tiny rock
in the middle of a big ocean and all the
animals have to go somewhere.
So they all go to this little tiny rock.
So you go on this beach,
St Andrews,
Bang,
you've got 400,000
king penguins,
you know,
on this one little beach is just thick
with animals and,
and it had a lot of ceiling.
But now the first year of coming back
and so you literally get to these
beaches and you kind of got to try and
make your way through the penguins and
the seals to actually get ashore.
It's that crazy.
And one of my favorite things to do
there is I just laid down on the beach
and all the little tiny baby first seal
pups,
little tiny things with bobbly heads.
They all come up and they pile on top of
you.
And it's just amazing,
amazing experience to be in.
Amongst so many animals that are just as
inquisitive about you as they are.
Yeah.
There's some crazy,
crazy shots there.
Wow.
That's so beautiful.
It's a,
it's a stunning spot.
I've got,
um,
I've got some images somewhere as well.
The,
the perspective that you gain from
visiting all these amazing places.
Um,
and then when you come and you talk to
people that sort of live in one city and
never leave that,
you feel bad for those people.
Everyone's got their own,
their own path.
You know,
everyone's thinking.
You all zen.
That's true.
I,
I don't,
I mean I guess a little bit of pity,
maybe a little bit of like,
Oh,
you don't have a passport that sound
fortunate to live in this wildlife
adventure.
I mean,
it's an insane path and I think there's
something cool about talking to people
that travel all over the world.
It's like they have a perspective.
It's almost like they're like,
oh,
okay.
Like you go to a bunch of different
places,
you see a bunch of different ways that
people live and you go,
oh,
all right,
there's not really one way to do this.
There's no better way or bad way.
There's just different ways to do so,
which is,
that's what you see everywhere.
Um,
yeah,
you know,
I've got some friends who left high
school and they married the local
mechanic and don't even have a passport
to dude who's married and mechanic what
I'm talking about.
Female girls,
but whatever.
Same difference,
but basically never left the town that
they grew up in.
You know,
and that's it.
That's what they do.
Maybe that town as mushrooms and the
trip in a different way.
There's a lot of cow Patty Duke who do,
do,
do.
But I think about that when I,
when I think of traveling to different
cultures and experiencing these really
incredibly varied ways of living that
people have.
I always think new look at all the
different varieties of,
of life.
Like I posted this instagram video last
night of this jellyfish that I saw in an
aquarium and I remember thinking when I
was looking at that jellyfish,
like what if that thing was on another
planet?
We would think it would be the most
fascinating discovery that man is.
Don't even get me started.
There's jellyfish that are immortal,
immortal,
like literally they live for live
forever.
Look at that thing.
I think.
Yeah,
that was a great little video
cephalopods.
I think if you're talking about aliens,
underwater cephalopods is where it's at.
And cephalopods the Nautilus Nautilus,
Shell Octopus,
squid and cuttlefish and cuddle fish on
my favorite creature.
Actually,
Jamie,
there's a video on my youtube channel
called Adam verse cuttle fish.
You'll,
you'll dig it.
Um,
me just free diamond with the
cuttlefish,
but they're the most amazing,
amazing,
great trailer and the alien in so many
respects.
And a lot of the research on them is
only like five years older.
So we're still working stuff out because
they're the fastest color and texture
chamber in the world.
They like a neon sign,
pulsating color shoe.
I think it's about 390 DPI is the
resolution they can predict on this
scheme.
It's just phenomenal.
They have three hearts.
They don't have hemoglobin that I've
read blood.
They've green blood.
It's kind of a copper based blood.
I'm a little bit less inefficient.
Hence they have three hearts.
Um,
they have like a jet engine,
they pump water and around their head
and push it out a little nozzle at the
front.
Um,
look at that thing.
It's like an octopus with tiny legs in
the cephalopod family as well.
So this one's got a cuttlefish bone,
so it's neutrally buoyant.
It's kind of just floating off the
surface,
but it looks like whatever's behind it.
It's very,
very good at camouflage and also
communicates via color as well.
But what we couldn't work out for many
years,
once you put them in a dark box and they
will still mimic.
So you put in a box with no light
whatsoever.
They
will still mimic whatever is behind them
even though there's no light there to
actually use.
And then they would also mimic color and
get their eyes.
What do you mean they will mimic what's
behind them?
I mean there are many youth,
a wall put a cuttlefish in a box pitch
black and you put a triangle,
a triangle shape behind them.
They will mimic on the other side of
triangle shape in their skin.
And we still,
we're still trying to work out how they
do this because there's no light.
And we knew that they did it with a
color that their eyes don't see color.
I see black and white,
heavy amount of contrast.
We actually only two years ago,
they worked out in their skin.
They see color via their skin or their
eyes.
I can go on.
It's crazy.
There's sexual reproduction is mom is
really cool.
They don't.
They have a lack of our offices that
don't have too many artifices to use.
So we asked and are.
So what they do is the male cuttlefish
gets an arm and sticks it up his
nostril,
we'll call it a nostril.
It's an artifice,
whatever,
and pulls out a sack of sperm and then
goes up to the female and then sticks
that arm with the sacral sperm.
Lauren up her nostril,
left nostril.
And that's how they reproduce what?
Yeah,
it's sack fisting.
Take a sack of sperm and they fixed it
up
your nose and nostrils.
The same orifice they use for smelling.
Um,
we call it industrial,
but it's just a whole.
It's just a whole.
But it's the closest one to their sexual
watch it here.
Oh God,
I'm not prepared for this.
January cuddles grabbing her.
And he died straight after that.
Actually.
Yeah.
They only live for about 18 months.
So the Australian giant cuttle fish,
different cuttlefish,
different things,
but 18 months.
So they do that.
They reproduced,
they die.
My Friend,
Remy Warren has this show called Apex
Predator where he,
um,
he travels to all these different
environments and tries to figure out how
these various apex predators hunt their
food and how they do it.
And he said without a doubt that the
most fascinating one that he did he
studied was the octopus and it's like
they are some kind of an alien creature.
And when I didn't know until he came on
the show,
like how quickly they can change into
the background that was like completely
camouflaged,
not just in color but also in texture.
They mimic the texture behind them.
It's,
I mean,
it's hard to find them when you're scuba
diving.
It's actually hard to find them because
they look exactly like what a them.
Um,
they have so many,
like the more research you do on,
they're just amazing.
They have the intelligence of a six year
old child.
Um,
and so they've been actually class
recently as like,
I forget the word,
like sentience beans or something like
that.
So they're in the same class as dogs and
monkeys and dolphins not do tests on
them that harmed them.
Basically.
Biggest still going for Sushi.
Oh yeah,
you can kill them.
You just can't.
You can still get grilled octopus.
It's like grilled six year old.
I mean you probably,
it's a strange thing that we do and we
decide what we will eat,
what will we.
And it varies hugely uncultured well
that we don't eat dog here,
but mean I made a mistake of watching a
piece.
I think it was a vice piece on that
Yulin dog festival and I was like,
whoa man,
good Lord it.
But again,
it's entirely cultural because if you
were an Indian person who is a Hindu and
you see what we do to cows,
that would be equally,
if not more deserving because their cows
are wholly what I love.
I haven't done much India,
but I've done the poll is that,
no,
we don't eat this cow,
this cow sacred,
but this buffalo,
it's tasty.
You just like what the together with the
bird egg people and try to figure this
out.
It's just when you see certain
traditions that exist in these cultures
and try to decipher like how,
how they got started,
there's always a reason for it.
You can't go back.
You can always just send a recent of why
this started.
This was,
you know,
don't eat pork here will you get
Salmonella and it kills you.
You know,
of course.
Always a risk that's for kosher food and
things along those inspirational people
have this hugely complex system of who
you are allowed to talk to,
who you're allowed to marry.
This things called skins and takes a
long time to come and get your head
around.
But when you look at the science behind
it,
it's the most efficient way ever
conceived by humanity to ancient
cultures to prevent inbreeding.
So you're not allowed to talk to your
sister.
Can't talk to her and Kinda talk to
because he might have sex with him so I
won't have sex.
My sister.
We would trust.
That's gross,
but they can't talk to their sister.
Yeah.
And generally their mother as well.
Well that makes you want to fuck your
sister more.
It's like damn.
It must be good.
I'm trying to keep me away from her.
Yeah,
you're a little twisted.
I'm not saying me,
man.
I'm just,
you know,
hypothetically this person that lived a
long,
long time ago when they came up these
weird rules.
Um,
is it possible for a restroom?
Just be two seconds and then we're gonna
come back.
Maybe some climate change will.
Sure,
yeah,
absolutely.
Short reproduction.
What do you like your watch,
man?
That was a cool watch that um,
it's,
it's actually quite cheap.
That's cool.
Look.
And it doesn't have to be expensive
copays.
You like to have a look?
No,
I'm good.
Don't worry about it.
Alright,
we'll be back again.
I when the bladder war,
I like to find someone who could sit
here and drink coffee and whiskey as
long as we can.
Oh,
what the fuck's wrong?
Do you think my bladder has changed?
It must've changed a.
This is not stuff that I was born with.
I think it's just from doing three hour
podcasts like like right now if I had to
pee it will be a struggle.
I've been sitting here drinking coffee.
I had a glass of whiskey with him,
Jack and coke diet coke of course.
Because of my diet.
Like a truck driver?
Yeah,
developed it.
I wonder.
I'd like to have a competition with
truck drivers so who could hold their
pis longer?
They could pull over though.
Truck driver could pull over like two
hours in.
Just pull over man.
I've left podcast before.
I have.
I've timed it poorly.
You know what it is if I don't pee right
before the show it could get because
then I might've gotten it hours without
peeing.
It's weird.
It doesn't break the seal.
You know like when you eat,
when you're drinking first,
then you gotta go every 20,
30 minutes.
Sometimes it happens to me.
Hmm.
It got the UFC event one time.
I shouldn't have gone at all.
I have just held it will,
you know,
where it breaks me,
monster energy drinks.
I don't drink those fuckers anymore,
but at the UFC they have those and
sometimes you know,
you're doing six hours of commentary,
you want a little caffeine,
but uh,
I would have those monsters and man that
I would have to piss like within an
hour.
It's crazy.
Like there's some stuff in them,
like there are some form of a diuretic
in some way.
Maybe you would know this.
I looked up something yesterday when I
was eating a burrito on a hot sauce.
There's something called Xantham gum and
yeah,
and it was like a thickening agent is
what I read.
But when I was looking on the wikipedia
about Xantham Gum,
it says it's a,
it's used as a heavy,
a laxative.
Really.
Then in my head I was just like,
maybe that's what's making people shit
themselves with a lot of hot sauces that
not the hot sauce could be.
Could be.
I think there's a reaction that your
body has.
Your stomach has to hot sauce to your
body.
Like what in the fuck?
And that makes you shit yourself to not
really necessarily shit yourself as much
as have to take a shit.
How the hell did you get their bladder
control?
Drinking hot sauce.
Xantham gum out of the room for 30
seconds.
Wow.
I've actually,
while I was kind of the toilet,
I just remembered pirates.
Yes.
Do you know why they have the earrings?
The Golden.
Because they're gay.
They're all gay.
Well actually you offered it right?
But they did say we're going to.
Sexuality is a big part of it.
Well that was why they would do it.
I mean they were.
They would discuss why they dress so
flamboyantly.
Yes.
But that's not why they were gold
earrings.
No,
it was actually payment.
Full burial.
So when you got washed over overboard,
you end up floating up on a beach
somewhere.
We'd go bury you in.
Then take the gold,
the golden.
That's a good deal.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I thought it was just to look cool.
Look like a bad ass with scarf was
women.
It was the oldest game.
It was.
There was women pirates.
But to be a woman pirate though,
you had to be able to be able to get
away with.
You had to look like a male basically.
You had to be able to get away with
giving away.
Yeah,
it'd be like a softball player and type
chick really likes crossfit thick neck
ones.
Still Very womanly,
but large style after traveling the
world for,
for while the last few years,
I'm really big fan of yoga pants on
airplanes.
Oh yes.
Yep.
They figured it out.
It's amazing that it took so long,
but now girls would just rocking them.
I'm like,
bitch,
you ain't going to yoga.
You just want everybody to senior
perfect ass.
How dare you walk around.
But men can't do that.
If you walk around with Yoga Pants and
your shaft is just bulging the front of
your pants,
people would think you're rude,
like it's quite fine and dandy.
It's sexist.
They're asked to be plump and right
there and all juicy and inviting.
But you can have your,
uh,
your man bits compressed and front and
center,
there'll be rude,
right?
At least on a plane full of people,
which is not acceptable.
A man can't walk around with Yoga Pants
on.
Very few do,
right?
Yeah.
I don't think I could.
I didn't think I could pull it off.
It's an argument for a large fanny pack
yoga pants and a large fanny pack for a
man.
It's like,
what is behind that thing?
Wouldn't you like to know?
My eyes are up here fucker.
Oh,
fanny pack.
That just cracks me up when you say
that,
but because you guys.
The Vagina is a vagina in England and
Australia as well.
But also we wouldn't be caught dead
wearing an actual fanny pack bumbag
would it be?
And then just not fashionable.
Um,
I wear one.
You wait one all the time.
I could see it's being useful.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
If you're not trying to get laid when
just rocket.
Do you want one?
I have them.
I'm trying to get laid.
So should we talk about climate change?
Is that something that you want to bring
up?
I'm just amazed at how many tangents
you've been able to go on in the last
few hours.
It's impressive where you're in this
with me.
Yeah,
I know.
It's both our faults.
Okay.
Um,
so I don't know how much to talk about
here.
Like you've got such an intelligent
audience either.
I don't listen,
don't,
don't get too crazy little monkeys out
there listening to.
So I guess first thing is don't shoot
the Messenger.
Normally when someone starts talking
about climate change,
they look for reasons to shoot them.
Basically you need to,
you know,
it's got such a political aspect to it
and let you got to disassociate that and
just look at the science,
you know,
and also take the whole.
I hate the word belief.
I believe in climate change.
Well two plus two equals four.
If you believe it's fine.
It doesn't really change the fact,
you know,
anyway,
it's got a whole lecture on this.
So I do,
do you do ted talks on this?
Uh,
I had,
uh,
to,
to Chada on board the ship.
We had a mission Bluetooth,
which was all trying to ocean
conservation,
Sylvia Earle,
heads of Ted talk.
Fascinating.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I just listened to them basically.
But um,
so then you have climate,
which is what a big mistake people make
is they go,
oh,
it's weather,
it's cold outside.
Well,
that's climate.
Climate is weather over very large
timescales and that's a big one that
people get wrong straight away.
Um,
but when you look at,
say 14,000
peer reviewed articles about climate
change,
there's only 24 that reject global
warming.
So to have this whole thing,
there's a debate going on.
There is no debate.
There's a debate.
Twenty four people debate.
No,
I know what you're saying.
I'm just joking.
You've seen the documentary,
I assume merchants of doubt.
Um,
I think that one might have ms.me
actually.
It's pretty fascinating.
I had Michael Shermer in here who's the
head of skeptic magazine magazine.
Michael Shermer is a pretty famous
skeptic and he was with the skip toy
one.
You ripped him a new one.
That was guys.
He did it himself a full.
Um,
but schermer is much more reasonable and
intelligent man.
But he was,
I'm talking about this documentary.
We actually brought it up.
I forgot that he was in it.
It was a documentary where it showed
that the same people that were spreading
misinformation that were actually paid
to spread misinformation about
cigarettes,
about cigarettes being addictive were
the very same people that were spreading
misinformation about climate change.
People will sell outfit.
Yeah,
exactly.
And they're just good at it.
They're good at bullshit.
Those 20 full people.
Yeah.
You look into it.
They're all paid by the state,
by the oil petroleum.
It's a little bit.
Yeah.
So I mean you and me,
we now and the whole world kind of come
around to,
in the last two years,
the world is warming.
We know this well,
no matter which way you look at what's
happening,
something's going on and people normally
go,
oh well that's,
you know,
solar and stuff like that going on.
But if you remove the solo,
you know from the equation,
it's still going up.
It's still going up because we
understand the soul cycle's quite well,
we've done a lot of research on them so
we know what's going on.
And then the other thing that people
always say,
oh,
it's happened over and over again
throughout history,
you know,
and so this one's 800,000
years and yeah,
you see it psychically going up and
down.
But I always like to look at the
averages and the average is,
is kind of CEO to with an average and
maybe to 25 parts per million.
You know what we're up to now,
what were like 403 at the moment.
Okay.
So the average been to 50,
never got higher than 300 and we now are
at 400 or something.
So we're off the charts when it comes to
that and temperature the same.
It's always been a little colder than it
actually is today.
And that's just because you know,
earth rotating around the sun.
A little bit of progression here,
a little bit of a tilt here.
We understand this quite well,
otherwise we won't be able to make
observations of the skies as closely as
we do.
So people always go,
yes it's solar,
but if you look at solar since 1960,
70,
it's been going down.
But the amount of solar radiation,
the amount of energy that Sun's putting
out that hits planet earth has been
going down and yet temperature has been
going up big time.
So right there you kind of can get away
from the whole.
It's just natural cycles.
Something's really going on that's not
meant to be there.
And so as of last year,
we crossed 400 parts per million co two
in the atmosphere and actually between
look at that spike.
That's crazy.
From the 19 tens to 2015,
this is from 400,000
years ago.
No,
but I mean the last spike.
Oh yeah.
Which shows 19.
Ten to 2015.
That's when it goes completely vertical.
Yeah.
Straight up,
straight up.
And so,
I mean even in the last 12 months we've
had the sharpest.
Rosin Sio two as well,
have about just under three parts per
million.
So it's still increasing.
It's not slowing
down at all.
It's actually increasing big time.
Spike is crazy.
It's weird to look at.
Yeah,
it's like a rocket ship taking off
straight up in the air.
Anytime you see this,
you know any scientist sees this,
Ooh,
that's not,
that's not normal.
That's not what things.
A cyclic.
They don't just go the hockey,
whatever.
You got hockey stick.
Do you remember when an inconvenient
truth came out and so many people were
attacking Al Gore immediately
afterwards,
boy,
those conservatives,
they fucking piled on.
It's almost like they were just trying
to avoid the information,
getting out,
just trying to keep business as usual
for as long as possible.
I haven't wondered what's the world we
currently live in.
If our goal became president.
Oh,
he should've fucked over that.
That was one of the weirdest elections
that were like,
yeah,
yeah.
We know you won,
but whatever.
George Bush's second term come out,
we never get rid of a president in wool.
Do you always have.
They always get to terms with is John
Curry was the second term,
right?
It was Al Gore was the first one,
Wasn't it a algorithm?
An algorithm running against him the
first time and then John Kerry did the
second time.
Was that what it was?
And even John Kerry,
there was some fuckery,
there was some fuckery when it came to,
there was,
did you ever.
Well,
it's totally different subject,
but there was a fantastic hbo
documentary on called Hacking Democracy
and it was all about how these diebold
machines that were created these
election counting machines,
we're,
they were huge contributors to the
Republican Party,
the diebold corporation,
which changed her name afterwards,
but they also,
they engineered some sort of a back door
into the system,
like clearly there could be hacked and
they showed it like without doubt on the
show,
on the,
in the documentary that you can hack
these machines and alter the results.
And these are the machines that they
used.
One Swish became president of receipts,
something.
Then remember the Dang d dangling Chads,
whoever it was.
It's messed up.
It's missed.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Let's,
um,
so I mean,
temperatures are rising.
We notice,
as I said,
worldwide,
I think we're about one point five at
the moment,
degrees above preindustrial northern
hemisphere to at the moment.
So where are they going?
Well,
that going towards about six degrees by
the end of the century.
Six.
Yeah,
so you'll talk to people and they'll get
four point five,
um,
any climate scientist,
you get this all the time,
so you to tell me what's going to happen
by the end of the century and they got a
four point five degrees Celsius
temperature rise and then you have a
drink with them afterwards and they're
like,
well I can prove four point five to 99
point nine,
nine percent probability,
but I can prove six at 92 percent
probability,
you know what I mean?
And so they don't ever print it because
they can't be 100 percent certain.
This is a few more variables.
They need more data that need more
research.
They need more calculate.
That's the real number.
That's actually where it's heading.
So that's why you get these great
graphs.
You see this
graph here,
it's a few years old.
It says,
oh,
it may only get to one point five
degrees.
We were already there.
So the lowest end of this is already
happened.
The higher end is,
is is about six degrees depending on the
different research that you do,
but I think it's just good that people
realize that scientist won't publish
something unless they're 100 percent
certain on something and so there's a
lot of things that they're pretty
certain on.
They'll tell you over a drink later on,
but they weren't published it and that
generally.
That's why every year it seems to get
worse and worse than predictions.
I'm positive proof of global warming is
visual visual joke than anything
[inaudible] I don't think.
I think that people found out.
People look better.
Those little tiny underwear.
This is,
by the way,
the vast majority of the people that
enjoy this show.
Listen,
I'm trying to talk about it more than 90
percent so that that picture,
they're like,
what the fuck did they see?
There's just an old school bloomers from
the 19 hundreds,
early 19 hundreds to the little tiny
bikini underwear that the young ladies
like to wear today,
which I support.
That's a global warming is bringing us.
He Ha fucking fire up.
The higher up the carbon out.
Skip through this as quickly as I can.
What's going on?
Why is this all happening while we're
pumping out non billion tons of carbon
dioxide per year.
And the vast,
what I like about this graph is that you
can see that about three and a half
billion tons is actually coming from
coal and about three and a half from
petroleum.
So it actually just removing coal from
the equation is like a third more than.
That's China is a big one,
right?
He's straight.
He's got heaps of coal fire power
plants.
Australia will America has some as well,
right?
But China is a,
they have a huge problem with it,
right?
You need an ancient technology,
uh,
hundreds of years old.
We got much better stuff these days.
Okay.
Instead of just going over these graphs
and showing how we're fucked,
what can be done?
Is there something that can be done?
Do you,
do you have a solution yet?
Adam crop for president of the world.
I couldn't put up with politicians.
No.
You could put.
Um,
I,
yeah,
I have,
I can just skip straightforward to the
solutions if you like,
but we have to ride horses or no,
no,
I just,
you know,
just want to point out that,
different things are going on.
Cyclones or hurricanes are getting worse
and worse.
The more powerful.
There's more of them.
Jetstreams messed up.
Um,
sea level rise.
Oh,
you know,
they say maybe two meters,
but once you factor in positive feedback
loops and stuff like that,
it can be,
can be significantly higher.
So you come back to the old mold Steve's
thing,
you know,
they're,
they're gone.
I'm interesting men.
Do you ever heard of this guy?
No.
He was the president of the Maldives.
He was the first democratically elected
president of 100 percent Muslim country
to be like carrots,
like a rabbit out of his teeth.
He was a marine biologist,
but he's looking at.
He's biting his lower lip,
like he's a.
is that just a weird face?
They caught him,
but he spent,
he spent six years in jail and 18 months
in solitary confinement.
Whoa.
For what?
For going for talking about climate
change.
Yes.
It's crazy.
He wanted to beat him in jail.
He's.
He's currently in jail I think at the
moment for talking about climate change.
Yeah.
Wow.
Who put them in jail?
The next president that came in.
Anyway,
but so what you have is this huge
potential sea level when we go,
oh,
to me does it.
Most people go,
oh yeah.
To me to build a wall.
Whatever people in Shanghai would
disagree.
But anyway,
you have the sea level rise potential
with positive feedback loops.
So water vapor is probably the most well
understood.
You know,
more,
more hotter.
You have the more water vapor you have
and that cycles back on itself and it
gets harder.
Another one is like the permafrost in
Siberia and stuff like this.
So as this area thor's it really solid
and methane.
Then cycles and it gets more and more
and more.
So if you take this all into account,
then you get a huge sea level rise of
about 60 meters is the potential of what
can go on 16 meters.
No,
no,
six zero,
60,
60.
Convert that defeat at your leisure
about 200 feet,
oh my God,
but show a graph.
One thing,
show an image of Australia with 60 meter
sea level rise,
whereas the states there,
Florida where it's good,
but get rid of Florida.
California,
let's say,
has plenty of water.
Now,
problem solved.
You've got a nice little stuff in the
middle.
We a plan in place to live.
You know stuff in the middle.
There's no one there anyway,
right now,
most of years gone.
Good,
good riddance.
Then you also have the ocean
acidification.
Do you know much about that one?
Yes,
I have read about that.
That's one of the more disturbing
aspects of the.
Not just ocean acidification,
but less oxygen and more dead zones.
All the last time this happened,
which is it's happening and it's only a
couple of decades away.
Ninety six percent,
96 percent of the marine species on this
earth perished.
When was this?
A 252 million years ago while we bounce
back.
We did.
It's called the great dying at the
current trends and what's going on.
Two thousand and 50.
We're looking at this ocean
acidification event happening,
so that means that old coral reefs won't
be able to grow carl anymore.
Uh,
no shellfish can grow shells anymore.
I'm basically the combined calcium
carbonate out of the water anymore.
They're basically then the chemistry
doesn't work anymore and that at the
moment is looking at 2050 Jesus.
And that's pretty much,
that's all your fish species.
Everything that's,
that's a lot of stuff going.
I saw something online about,
there was a solution that they were
proposing where they would put scrap
iron all throughout the ocean and then
that would somehow or another attract
algae and that would uh,
basically seeding a whole heap of life
to balloon phyto plankton.
And then the base is the start of the
food chain.
You're going,
hey,
here's a whole heap of stuff for you
that makes you grow faster and bigger
and stronger.
And so it seeds that.
And so yeah,
it will absorb a large amount of co two
for sure.
Not Enough.
It's,
it's tough.
The,
the ocean is doing a damn good job at
the moment of absorbing a lot of CEO
two.
And that's why we have this kind of 40
year lag thing going on because the
ocean absorbs a lot of heat and it's a
heat sink,
you know,
but I mean,
this one here,
this is from,
this is this month,
and you've got 12 degrees warmer in the
top.
It's crazy.
And Yeah,
about 12 degrees warmer than standard
than normal arctic.
The Arctic basically didn't have a
winter this year.
It's just stayed.
Some stayed summer or kind of warm.
Twelve degrees Celsius warmer than
usual.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So that whole optic ice free sort of
thing that's not too far away.
It's actually not too far away.
It's closer than you think in Greenland
is thawing very,
very fast.
I mean if you look at the melts,
uh,
over 50 percent of greenland melted last
year.
Most of it refroze thank God,
but it,
it's melting over 50 percent.
Yeah.
As a graph in front of your 2015 mil
percentage was over 50 percent of it
melted.
I'm normally just over about 20 percent
melts per year,
but a large portion of melted was
greenland at one point in time.
Green is that with the reason why they
called the Greenland?
Just messed up the naming because
Iceland,
I know Iceland and Greenland should be
the other way around,
but aura.
But I'm going there for the first time.
Actually in June.
Go on a national geographic explorer.
I'm doing svalbard,
Iceland,
Greenland.
Super excited.
So again,
I love these charts and graphs,
but we're almost out of time here.
Where we're at.
Three minutes.
What can we do?
Well,
yeah.
What can we do?
Um,
you need to save the children.
But I prefer save the animals.
So that's what you like.
The animals one,
the people.
What?
I'm scared of.
Toddlers,
they kill more people than terrorists.
I'm scared of them.
Toddlers do.
Toddlers in the states kill more people
in terrorists.
Um,
how do they kill people?
Shoot them.
Generally know those guns are killing
people,
not toddlers.
Right?
Well,
just keep the fucking guns away from the
tolerance and don't kill anybody.
How many people get killed by toddlers?
It's a lot.
It's crazy.
Really?
Toddlers with guns.
Website.
I should be a new band.
Jamey.
Thinking about a band name.
Toddlers with guns.
Toddler.
Yes,
death by toddler,
there is a million different things you
can do with climate change.
There is the thing that most people do
is,
oh,
here's a great idea.
We need to do that one idea.
No,
we need to do all of them.
We need to do them all now and we need
to do them all 20 years ago basically.
That's why I keep saying really have you
tried turning it on and off again?
Like we kind of do need to kind of do a
full reset,
but we need to start.
We have the technology to get to do all
these things and keep living standards
out.
We have the technology,
we just need to start acting on it.
Whether
it be hyperloop,
hyperloop is a great idea.
Why aren't we doing that?
Um,
and the big thing that always comes to
me,
you know,
put solar panels on your roof.
Efficiency is a huge one.
Change to led,
led bulbs,
all that sort of stuff.
There's a million different things and
we've gone over this a million times as
well,
but always comes down to money.
And I always say there's lots of money
out there to be done.
There's lots of money to be used and
where you can raise taxes,
carbon taxes,
a great way,
very efficient,
been proven over and over.
It's a great way to actually curb
climate change.
You could just print the money like the
bankster that always works.
You could,
I'm going to get in a lot of trouble for
this,
but you could take a little bit of the
war budget,
that military budget and how you're
going to get in trouble for that.
That's really amazed.
I do climate change talks among moment.
I talk about reducing military budgets
and putting it towards good climate
change.
That sort of freedom.
My posing.
I love team American.
That's a great man.
Um,
so I mean I actually did,
I started a nonprofit,
but it's more of an idea at the moment
called world without war.
And that was all about hey,
let's take 50 percent of the military
budgets and put it towards large
infrastructure projects are planting
trees,
build a hyperloop.
And once you do the figures,
like once you have,
oh,
I've got $2,000,000,000,000,
what can I do for $2,000,000,000,000?
You'd be amazed.
You can give free education for
everyone.
You can convert all those coal fire
power plants into renewables.
You can completely reduce deforestation,
you can do zero website world without
or.org.
I said it's just an idea.
Just started.
Um,
but that's the last one I'd like to end
on because I know we're running out of
time is buckminster fuller and I think
he put it best,
which is it is now highly,
highly feasible to take care of everyone
on earth at a higher standard of living
than any have ever known.
It no longer has to be you and me.
Selfishness is unnecessary.
War is obsolete.
It's a matter of converting the high
technology from weaponry to luminary.
That's a beautiful quote.
But how do you,
how do you deal with Isis?
How do you deal with Isis?
Once again,
I'll get in trouble.
Don't,
ah,
don't build isis in the first place.
Don't give them over weapons.
But once you,
uh,
once you do have them with all the
weapons,
what is this?
People getting shot by toddlers on a
weekly basis this year.
It's real.
Oh my fucking God.
More Americans who are two year olds are
shooting people.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Or in October,
2015,
it said 43 instances.
What?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
This is insane.
In 2015,
at least 13 toddlers have been,
have inadvertently killed themselves
with firearms.
18 more injured themselves.
10 injured other people and two killed
other people.
So I'm still at children.
Well,
we're just,
it's not the kids.
It's people that leave the fucking guns
around kids.
That's what it says.
You didn't Australia,
we have no guns.
Yeah,
we had the largest massacre on earth.
I'm 36 people or something got killed
and we just tend to run.
Went,
eh.
You know what
we don't against worked rather well we
did for you guys.
But again,
you have the population of Los Angeles
and in China and Hong Kong land.
Yeah.
There's,
there's something like a certain.
I think there's hundreds of millions of
guns in America.
I think there's as many guns as there
are people and there are trillions of
rounds of ammunition and the gun people
say if there was really a gun problem,
you know,
it would all our guns and all our ammo
through is really a gun problem.
I fucking just reasonably suggested,
reasonably suggested that people that
are mentally unbalanced maybe shouldn't
have guns and people and the fucking
hate from the far right,
but like the people that really believe
in the second amendment says though,
right,
it's a right to keep and bear not but no
buts.
I believe in the second amendment,
but no,
no,
no buts,
no buts.
Guns.
Isn't it like a well armed militias and
stop government?
Yeah,
that's what's supposed to be.
Well,
that's what they think.
Like those,
the Oregon people who we never figured
out who first dubbed them.
Y'All kinda whoever that guy is,
Kudos to you or her ma'am or sir,
it's great.
Great Name.
But uh,
yeah,
those people,
there's a lot of people like that that
think will,
they're coming for our guns.
It's education.
When it comes down to it,
the best thing,
money for dollar for dollar that you can
do is education.
If you educate women in the world that
have less children and that that solves
a lot of problems right there to the
truth.
I'm the only other thing.
Dollar for dollar education is the best
way and especially educating women and
in third world countries especially,
but that was the way 20 years ago I feel
now we've gotten to the point where we
really.
I said 40 year lag,
so what's happening now?
We're not going to see for 40 years.
We need to do something major.
We need to do something right now and
that's why I quite like the world
without war thing because for every
dollar you spend lobbying to get people
to reduce their military budget,
you multiply,
you're going to get a lot more money
diverted to something that
is better for society basically.
I mean that's whether it's
infrastructure or hyperloop or plant
trees or get electric cars,
whatever,
throw the money at it.
Well,
very few people would argue with you
that the world would be better off
without war.
I think the real argument,
everyone argues with me on that one,
I think the real argument would be
whether or not the rest of the world
would cooperate.
Like we all would agree.
Let's just like ramp down our gun
production or missile production.
Let's ramp it down and everybody relaxed
and let's reallocate those resources.
Most people would say that'd be a great
idea,
but who's going to do it as well?
You know?
Is Isis going to do it?
I like these example
of Indian Pakistan,
India and Pakistan keep raising the
military budgets every year to compete
with each other because they want to
make sure that we're spending
the same amount as the other guy because
this guy,
the other guy,
you go to these two countries and you
go,
Hey,
here's a treaty.
Just like all the trade agreements,
whatever that you sign and you reduce
the military budget by 50 percent and
the other guy promises to do it as well.
Suddenly you're reducing war which are
more for.
And you're also helping a relieving a
heap of money available for Climate
Change Abatement.
So I think it's a win win situation,
but all my Lord I get in trouble.
We're not talking about.
Well you signed your hippie.
Got Idealistic Hippie.
That's what the problem is.
The people right now are,
yeah,
fuck this hippie shutting their iphone
off right now.
Fucking hippie.
I hate when Rogan as hippies on.
But who wants war man?
Nobody wants war.
So maybe Jocko.
Jocko.
My aunt is it.
Most people don't want it,
you know,
they date,
they reluctantly accept the fact that we
have disputes and then we have a armies
to handle that and keep us safe.
But if you ask them,
would it be better if we just took that
money?
And instead of like having all this
military spending on climate change.
Yeah.
But then there's also those people that
are in the military that don't have jobs
anymore.
Like you know how many soldiers,
like we have less soldiers.
I'm sure we can get jobs for them that
don't involve killing people with as
many different ways to do this.
You can.
This is all very reasonable.
I just don't know.
Yeah,
no.
I said,
I'm amazed at how much kickback I get
from that one thing,
but I normally don't mention it.
I don't mean to make climate change.
I don't want to convolute it with
something like that.
It's such a perfect idea.
A perfect idea is in that console a lot
of problems and at the timeframe that we
need to solve them because everything
else,
if you look at the climate,
Paris talks,
right?
Cop Twenty one,
so the first time they got together
talking about climate science,
they eventually went,
okay,
195 countries.
We agree something's gone wrong and we
need to prevent the earth and warming to
two degrees Celsius.
Well,
six months later we're already there,
you know,
so and,
and they,
they're not agreeing to do anything for
five years as well,
so they don't even start to do anything
five years.
Like if we wait for politicians to do
something about this,
we're so screwed.
We really are.
Well,
that's one of the problems with having
politicians is that they're not experts.
They're not experts in anything.
They're experts in figuring out how to
get people to vote for him.
That's it.
Most politicians,
they're not the best at anything.
They're certainly not like exemplary
human beings who are beyond reproach.
The good egg,
you know,
they're good at debate,
so like other than Bernie Sanders,
I mean Bernie Sanders seems to be a
pretty exemplary guy.
Believe or not believe in socialism.
Argue it as you may.
He seems like a great guy with some
pretty good ideas about the world,
but we're at a time,
one at a time.
Adam.
Got to see how quickly that guys is.
Three hours and 15 minutes,
man.
Right about that.
Something like that were over.
We went over.
We don't give a fuck over here.
Thank you very much.
So let's do this again man.
How often are you in la?
I have no idea,
but hey,
I'll come back next year.
You're all over the place,
man.
Come,
come around and come visit us,
but thank you very much.
Really appreciate it.
It's been a great pleasure and hey,
keep up the good work chart.
You are really doing some amazing stuff
here.
I don't think people tell you that
enough that we're listing all the way
back in Australia and we're loving what
you're doing.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate that.
All right.
Thank you friends.
That's it for this week.
You fuckers.
I'll see you soon.
Bye.
Big Kiss.